Oh righty Jane,
what's happening?
I'm here.
You are here.
You made it.
And I'm excited too.
Thanks for doing this.
Appreciate it.
So your story is a very fascinating story.
You got a brain injury and you decided to make a game to help your brain
recover.
Now,
what led you to even attempt something like that?
I've never heard of anything like that in the past.
Well,
I had been designing games professionally and researching them for 10 years.
By the time I hit my head and it was not my first instinct.
Oh,
I have a brain injury.
Let me make a game.
But you know,
about a month into the recovery,
I wasn't getting any better.
I was really depressed and anxious.
Uh,
I mean I was,
it was like the lowest point of my life.
And I knew from my research that when we play games,
you know,
we have more optimism,
we're more determined.
We're better able to ask people for help,
right to team up with us,
be your allies.
And I just figured,
well,
uh,
this is like the worst I've ever felt in my life.
Maybe if I can bring some of that game full spirit to recovery,
I could kind of jump start my brain back into healing.
So what was the nature of your injury?
Uh,
I mean it was,
it started out as just a normal concussion.
And,
uh,
so this is my public service announcement,
right?
Of the episode.
I was standing up from underneath and open cabinet and I'm a runner,
so I've really strong legs and I was just in a hurry and I've just full us right
up into the corner of the cabinet,
um,
hit my head.
And it was like classic,
you know,
my husband was joking around,
who's the president?
And I couldn't remember who the president was and I was like,
Oh shit,
that really bad.
All I could get hit in the head.
You couldn't remember.
This is Barack Obama.
It was,
and all I could remember was,
it's not George Bush anymore,
but I couldn't remember who it was.
Wow.
So just standing up and hitting the edge of the cabinet.
It was an,
uh,
an opening.
It was an omen cabinet.
So this is the PSA is,
you know,
shut cabinet doors because apparently I have now learned after this happened to
me that this happens to a lot of people and you can get a serious head injury as
like a football player by doing this.
So out.
Wow.
So just standing up.
So he stood up quick,
Bam.
Yeah.
Whacked your head.
Did you go unconscious or did not go on conscious,
you know,
saw stars and everything,
but you know,
a lot of concussions,
it takes a few hours,
the brain starts to swell and it's not till later that day that you really start
to feel like something's really wrong.
So,
um,
is that what happened to you?
Yes.
Yeah.
Um,
and you know,
it was,
there was no internal bleeding or anything.
Um,
and so,
you know,
the doctor said,
oh,
you'll be fine and you know,
give it a week,
maybe a couple of weeks.
I come back after month,
they tell me,
Oh,
you know,
some people,
if it doesn't heal in the first month,
it takes three months.
And if it doesn't heal in three months,
it might be a year.
And if it's not a year,
maybe you're stuck like this.
Were you experiencing the classic symptoms?
Like you couldn't like stare at the sun,
the sunlight would bother your eyes.
Loud noises.
Oh,
I mean,
all light.
Like if I,
I,
I would try to go into like a whole foods or fluorescent lights would feel like
I was like under fire from weapons.
I mean,
I couldn't,
I was,
I was in bed basically for three months.
Everything,
like all stimulus would make me nauseous and um,
migraines and everything.
So it was,
it's so it started out normal concussion,
but then it's kind of unraveled into what they call post concussion syndrome,
which is,
um,
which is a thing that I didn't know existed,
but a lot of people and the concussions take up to a year to heal.
Yeah,
they can.
Well,
I,
uh,
from working for the UFC,
I've seen people that neglect those.
Yes.
And it,
it gets really ugly.
Yeah.
I've also seen people that were great fighters.
There's a guy named Tj grant who was in line for a UFC title shot,
uh,
got a concussion.
I'm not even from getting kicked or punched,
it was from,
uh,
grappling exchange,
just bonked his head on something.
I've a,
I believe it was somebody's knee or someone's hip or something like that and
then was never the same again and has never fall again.
And it's been like,
I think almost two years.
Yeah.
And I mean that's something I've gotten actually pretty active in the research
community and trying to share information.
So it turns out like the first week of recovery,
uh,
can really determine if you're going to go into this extended,
you know,
it's going to take you three months,
six months,
a year,
um,
if you're not,
if you're not resting enough in that,
that first week.
So the first week it's critical that you just do nothing.
I mean,
they call it cognitive rest and basically you want to not do anything that is,
that feels difficult for you.
And so for me,
I couldn't read,
I could only watch TV shows I'd already seen before because having to process
plot Gnuplot was not,
uh,
was not helpful.
So I was walking like rewatching Buffy the vampire slayer because I seen them
all like a million times.
Um,
and so,
and yet,
you know,
keep the lights off if they,
keep sunglasses on indoors.
Um,
but the first 48 hours and then after that,
the first week,
uh,
if you can avoid over stressing your brain,
you have a much better chance to recover within the one to two week period as
well as people.
Yeah.
And people don't know people like they tried to,
I tried to go right back to work.
I was in the middle of writing my first book and it was due in a couple months.
I'm like,
I can't miss my deadline.
I've got to do this.
I've gotta power through.
I'm going to can barely unlike,
can't even see the screen.
But you're,
when you're,
you know,
when you have a concussion,
you're not thinking clearly,
you are not irrational person.
You're just,
you're just like,
I have to do this.
I have to try.
And other people will look at you and be like,
what's wrong with you?
You are,
you know,
totally out of it.
Why are you trying to work?
But you're not,
you don't have that same kind of rational decision making ability.
So sometimes,
you know,
a friend or a loved one needs to take you aside and say,
I'm not letting you do anything for this first week.
You've just got to let your brain,
yeah,
and this is correct me if I'm wrong,
but it's relatively new,
our understanding of what takes place after concussion and what you have to do
to recover.
Yeah,
no,
there's just last year it was a big study that came out showing that four months
after concussion,
your,
your brain is still different.
There's still,
uh,
it's like a kind of a scarring that happens.
I get scab,
um,
that certain parts of the brain will still be thickened,
four months after,
even if you think you're feeling fine,
which means that you're still vulnerable.
You know,
if you were to get hit again,
it would be more dangerous.
And,
um,
and if you're still feeling symptoms after four months,
you know,
that's why it's like when you cut yourself open and you get the Scab,
uh,
you can't be picking at the scab by doing things that are triggering your
symptoms.
Yeah.
Wow.
So who was it that told you you got to settle down?
Well,
my,
you know,
my doctor had said that,
and of course I'm a,
I mean I'm a science geek that's,
I have a phd.
It's like my background.
Um,
and I was having my husband Google do Google scholar searches for traumatic
brain injury research cause I couldn't use the computer just like,
you got to figure,
is this normal?
I'm like,
I started feeling suicidal.
That was,
uh,
that was new for me.
And I'm like literally having him Google suicidal thoughts,
concussion because I'm like,
is this,
am I really suicidal?
Like,
am I rationally thinking I'm never going to able to work again.
My husband's got to take care of me.
I should just end it.
Which is what I was looking like.
The voices in my head were saying,
but it didn't feel,
you know,
it's,
that didn't feel like myself.
And so fortunately he was finding articles like,
wait,
one in three people with a concussion have suicidal thoughts and that is
actually a reaction to the neurochemistry.
Um,
when you have a concussion,
you don't have dopamine in the reward pathway,
reward pathways,
which means your brain can't anticipate anything good in the future.
You become like completely unable to imagine that you'll feel better,
that good things will happen for you.
And that's just like a perfect neurochemical foundation for suicide.
So you were able to remember how you used to think and so you knew this is not
the way I think.
Okay.
Yeah.
I mean it was,
I had,
I had like a,
I was able to distance myself a little bit from the thoughts where,
you know,
I would,
I,
you know,
cause I was just at home,
I wasn't going anywhere.
I would say to my husband,
like,
I feel like I have this voice that's saying,
you know,
you should kill yourself.
And I would,
I would talk about it because I didn't,
it,
I mean,
I think if you talk about it,
it,
it becomes less,
you know,
this feeling that you have that you have to really believe and,
and more like the thing that you can look at and try to figure out.
And um,
and uh,
and so it was like,
it just felt so weird to me because I'm like,
why?
I don't know.
I had never,
I never had that before.
Um,
and once I knew that it was a symptom of concussion rather than,
oh,
Jane has figured out that her life is terrible and logically she wants to kill
herself,
I was able to live with it.
And you know,
the research literature says they go away as the brain heals.
So I just thought,
okay,
and you know,
it might still,
I might still hear that voice for,
you know,
a few weeks or a few months,
but I know that that's a symptom of healing and not have actually feel.
So I'm just going to get on with it.
Now.
Is there a medication that you can take while this was going on?
Anything that speeds up the healing or anti inflammation medication?
Yeah.
Right.
So this is,
this is what's so hard about post concussion syndrome is there's nothing that's
been shown to speed it up.
I mean,
I was offered really powerful anti anxiety meds,
depression meds.
Um,
I chose not to take them because I just didn't want to go down that road.
I'd never taken them before.
Yeah.
Um,
and uh,
and there's no known therapies.
People have tried to do like oxygen deep oxygen therapy and hypobaric chamber.
Yes.
Yeah.
Um,
did you try any of that?
I did not try that.
Um,
but,
uh,
oh,
actually this is a sort of very exciting for me.
Um,
I,
because there's no good treatment for this.
When my game worked so well for me and I saw other people started using it at
work,
well for them,
we were able to get a grant from the NIH to test this with young athletes,
um,
through Ohio State University Medical Research Center.
We just released our findings last week that the game that I invented did
improve the post concussion syndromes and 100% of the people who used it,
uh,
compared to only 50% of people who didn't play.
So this is one of,
I mean,
this is one of the first validated treatments that can,
you know,
reduce the headaches and the nausea and the confusion and the,
difficulty.
So how did you get to the point where you wanted to experiment with a game?
Your,
you're recovering slowly.
Like,
I mean,
how slow is this taking?
Like how many months afterwards?
We still come.
Yeah,
well,
it's 34 days,
which I will,
I will never,
I don't like it.
It was,
it's emblazoned into my memory 34 days after I hit my head,
um,
that I was,
I'm always completely desperate.
I literally was saying to myself,
I'm going to kill myself or I'm going to turn this into a game because
I mean,
those two options,
it's so strange.
I know,
but so maybe be the only person in human history that's ever said that I'm going
to kill myself or I'm going to turn this into a game.
Yes,
yes.
Well,
you know,
I love writing my first book,
which was all about the psychology of games.
And I just thought to myself,
I should,
I got to prove it.
You know,
I,
I'm writing this book saying that playing games makes us happier and stronger
and more resilient.
I got to prove this theory.
I mean,
there's all other kinds of proof in the book,
but I'm like,
I'm going to live it.
Um,
and,
and that was just,
I just,
I didn't know how else to provoke the positive emotions.
And when we play games and his whole list of positive emotions that we feel when
we play games like curiosity and excitement and awe and wonder and pride,
and it's just like,
I gotta get some of these emotions because my doctor had said the more depressed
and anxious you are,
that can actually slow down the healing process.
It is actually a detrimental,
right if you,
if you fuel,
if you can feed the freshman anxiety
detrimental in,
in terms of measurable effects or detrimental in terms of the way you feel like
that,
uh,
from,
the brain's ability to heal the neurochemistry of depression is not conducive to
that.
So literally being depressed can slow down the physical healing of the brain
itself.
Yes.
And so they're like,
you know,
so try not to worry.
And I'm like,
well,
Geez,
I know.
I was like,
I can't get out of bed.
My books do.
I can't write.
My husband had lost his job a few months earlier and I'm like,
I may never work and I'm going to be like a Barista now.
This is like maybe if I can stand,
you know?
Yeah.
So,
uh,
so the 34 days,
yeah.
What is the 34 days were when it was at its worst,
is that right?
I just,
I mean,
it just,
everyone kept saying,
oh,
you'll be fine in a few days.
So we find a few weeks and then I went and saw my doctor after 30 days.
And then the doctor said,
uh Oh yeah.
By the way,
some people don't get better in a month.
Those people,
it often takes three months.
And uh,
for people who don't get better in three months and it often takes a year,
and if you're not better than a year,
then you might be like this forever.
And I was like,
oh my God.
It just,
it made me,
it kind of freaked me out.
So did you experiment with things during this time?
Like w w when you were researching?
I mean,
the only thing that I really experiment with was a tiny eat things with,
uh,
like Omega is the Omega three,
Omega six,
which are supposed to be good for,
for brain healing.
And there is some scientific literature on that where,
I mean doctors will say,
eat walnuts,
you know,
donuts.
Yeah.
Cause that's a good like,
uh,
it's,
it's available to them off real good.
It's,
I mean,
I suppose if it can be a capsule,
you can absorb things better from food.
What does walnut wallets,
it's like omega three omega six fatty acids in fish oil.
Uh,
I'm one of those weird vegans.
Oh,
how dare you.
What about a hemp oil?
Does that have yeah,
hemp is good.
Hemp is really good too.
Yeah.
But at the time,
I don't know,
the only thing I could kind of get it together to do was walnuts.
Hmm.
Okay.
So walnuts where it,
yeah.
[inaudible] is uh,
oh wife.
What do I do that well is a football player.
It was a famous football player and he suffered a lot of concussions and created
something called neuro one.
And uh,
it's uh,
a nootropic blend and he created it to deal with some of the symptoms that he
had had or some of the repercussions from all the head trauma that he had a,
so I was wondering if you'd ever tried anything.
I have not.
I know there are a lot of that sort of nutraceutical like interest in
experimenting with that.
I did not try that
because of the dopamine.
I was wondering like Serotonin,
like five HTP is really good for,
yeah.
Rebuilding Serotonin or building blocks with Sarah.
Yeah.
I didn't get it together to try any of that.
So you were just really struggling.
I was struggling.
I mean,
I would,
I would like,
I would sit on the bathroom floor and like cry for hours,
but quietly.
Oh.
Like I didn't want my husband,
different Gal.
Nice,
very polite.
And your depression,
it seems counter intuitive to someone who doesn't know anything like me that
you're saying that you could only watch like Buffy the vampire slayer because
he'd already seen it before,
but playing your game like decent part of yeah.
So stimulating,
right?
No,
and actually I couldn't play video games.
I would try to play like peggle I was,
I was like,
Tayga will be easy.
It's like a,
it's like a kind of pinball game,
uh,
where you shoot little pinballs around pop pigs and it's a,
and they played like the Hallelujah chorus,
every level you complete.
So I was like,
Yay,
and I'm successful.
They're like playing a prayed for me.
Uh,
I'm like,
that'll,
that'll really help.
Help me.
Um,
but even that was too stimulating.
so I couldn't play video games.
So the game,
I meant it was not a video game.
I mean,
we did eventually make an APP and a web version so people could,
could,
other people could play,
but it was more like just a set of rules that I would follow.
Um,
you know,
like you wouldn't like,
oh,
how do you play hide and seek or how do you play poker?
Just like learn the rules and play.
Uh,
so I just started making up rules for myself about doing things that you would
do in a video game,
like collecting power ups or spotting like making lists of the bad guys and all
the ways like where they would show up and what my strategies were for fighting
them.
And um,
coming up with a quest list.
So like,
what's something I can do in the next 24 hours to feel better,
like something concrete that I can accomplish.
And so just starting to approach my recovery with these really concrete gameful
strategies.
Um,
and really the,
the,
you know,
the first thing I did was I adopted the secret identity.
Like my avatar.
I was going to have an Avatar in my recovery and that was Jane the concussion
slayer.
Because I'm like,
oh,
I'm going to be like Buffy.
And Buffy did not choose to be the slayer.
Right?
Like they just hold her.
You're this layer,
you have to save the world.
And I'm like,
I did not choose to hit my head,
so I'm going to be like her and just arise to the occasion.
Um,
and kind of try to tap into my inner sense of determination and being a Badass.
And so what did you do like after you took on this persona or adopted the idea
of this Avatar?
Like what did you do?
Like what were your power ups?
Like who are the bad guys?
Like,
yeah,
yeah.
Um,
and bad guys wear anything that would trigger my symptoms.
so,
you know,
bright lights,
a crowded space,
um,
you know,
conversation,
I mean everything.
Um,
but the thing with,
with bad guys and like,
you know,
in a video game like,
oh,
there is,
there's a monster,
you don't run away.
You got to figure out how you're going to tackle it or get past it.
So,
and the same is true with recovery from any kind of injury or illness.
You have to keep testing the limits,
right?
Cause otherwise you wind up never getting better.
You kind of convinced that you're just flat on your back forever.
And this is sort of an aside,
but as I was doing all the research for this new book,
I found out that the number one predictor of disability after a back injury is
avoiding things that make your back hurt early on during recovery.
So you would think like,
oh,
you have to,
you know,
don't,
don't do anything that will make your back worse.
But the longer you keep that mindset,
that's a number one predictor of who becomes chronically disabled.
You're not able to work,
are there,
their life is affected in a major way and it's not,
the severity of the injury is not the severity of the pain.
Um,
and so with all kinds of injury and illness now,
because you get stuck in that pattern,
you never really thinking yourself as injured.
Yes.
Yeah.
And uh,
so you know,
it's like,
but with all of these things,
it's a careful balance.
So you have to recognize that the bad guys are bad.
I can't,
I can't go out and be in a crowded space for three hours.
It can't go to like a lady Gaga concert,
which I really wanted to do.
I'm like,
[inaudible] not going to do that.
Uh,
I said that it's kind of like a,
I'm like the next time she comes through that'll be like,
what am I epic wins when I can go see her.
Um,
but like you can do little things to task.
Let me go into the whole foods and see how many minutes I can make it before the
symptoms come back.
So you kind of like testing,
oh,
today was 30 seconds,
I got to leave.
Maybe next week it'll be five minutes.
And then you kind of start to get your life back because you don't want to get
on that course towards seeing yourself as is kind of chronically disabled.
So,
so that's,
you know,
you come up with these ways to,
to battle the bad guys,
you know,
every day.
And in the version that we tested with the NIH,
that's the game is activate three power ups a day.
So for me that might have been eating walnuts or like cuddling my dog,
cause that made me feel like safe and happy.
So anything that provokes a positive emotion,
if you're depressed and you have to really find what are the things that can get
through that depression and,
and still make you feel good.
So,
you know,
cuddle my dog,
I'd eat walnuts.
Do you do three of those a day?
One bad guy battle a day where he really test the limits to see if you're
getting better.
Um,
and one quest today,
which is the smallest possible thing you can do that we'll kind of move you in
the direction of your goal or recovery or just feel like something productive
that you want to do.
So I remember one time I,
my quest,
I decided to bake cookies for the Baristas at the coffee place down this area
is,
I'm like,
I,
I cause I could felt like I couldn't do anything for myself.
So I'm like,
I'm going to bake cookies for someone else today.
And,
uh,
as a result randomly I want of getting free coffee for a year because they were
like,
I cannot believe somebody came like down with this giant plate of cookies fresh
out of the oven.
Um,
but I did not,
I did not expect that.
Um,
but that was just like,
you know,
find one thing I can do today that will have a positive impact.
Um,
and that's,
that's the sort of,
there's other stuff you know,
in the game,
but that's sort of the main,
you're,
you're basically using game gain models to kind of structure your life to make
sure that you're staying engaged,
not hiding,
you know,
actually making progress to getting better.
This sounds really difficult.
More difficult than I think most people would ever imagine recovering from a
concussion would be.
I think most people would think that.
I wouldn't,
don't want to say most people,
let me just say what I would think.
I haven't had a concussion,
I don't think since I was probably 20.
And I would think that what it would be like would be like,
ah,
man,
it feels like shit.
Let me just lie down here.
I'll put ice on my head,
I'll watch TV or something and I'll just go to,
I'll take a lot of naps,
right?
Like you think it'll feel like a hangover or something like that.
The problem is that your thinking becomes muddled too.
So it's not just that you have these physical symptoms,
you're not able to think clearly.
You're not thinking like yourself.
And that can really lead to a lot of confusion,
bad decisions.
You know,
people,
uh,
they,
they try to hide the severity of the symptoms because they think that,
uh,
it will,
you know,
other people will judge them or they're like,
there's a lot of it that's very common.
I've now learned with concussions.
People hide the severity of symptoms because there's like,
you just,
you're,
you're not thinking clearly and you think it's important that other people not
really see.
Um,
but I've,
I've of become this sort of weird spokes person slash guru for concussions
because of my ted talk about it.
So every day,
literally I hear on Facebook or Twitter from someone who's like,
just been concussed and they're like,
what do I do?
Um,
and I actually,
uh,
I mean,
I,
you know,
I feel like,
okay,
I'm your ally.
And I'm like always,
you know,
sending direct messages to like random people.
I don't know,
checking in on them to see I'm feeling great thing because it's not even like if
your friends or family will not understand,
they will think,
oh,
you'll be out on the couch for three days and they expect you to be back to
normal.
And they don't understand why three months,
four months later,
you're still struggling.
It's not,
I mean,
it has not been discussed enough,
although I think that's changing now.
People,
especially with so many soldiers coming back with longterm,
uh,
symptoms of,
of the concussions.
No.
The other thing that's confusing to me with this is that in the beginning,
the first stage of your concussion,
it's critical.
You do nothing.
Right?
But then after a while you're like pushing it.
Like,
how,
how much time can I spend at whole foods for free?
Go,
right.
Yeah.
Like many people would think that that's sort of counter intuitive.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well,
in the is when the brain needs the most resources,
right?
So you don't mind early stages like,
yeah,
how many days?
So depending on the studies you read,
it'll say between 48 hours to one week is the most crucial stage where you want,
where you want the most cognitive rest and you want to avoid,
um,
it basically just exhausting the brain because blood,
anything you do that's cognitively demanding,
it directs blood flow to different regions of the brain.
You don't want your brain spending time trying to figure out your email instead
of,
you know,
because there's only,
there's only so much blood to flow around.
Um,
and you don't,
you don't want it to be spent and,
and,
and try and do an email will require so much more effort from you than it
normally would.
So it's a sort of like vicious cycle.
Um,
now eventually the brain kind of gets into this sort of,
I don't know,
spaces where it's like,
okay,
now we're working or you've got your,
you've got kind of your thickened up.
Um,
lesions that's going to take,
you know,
four months to kind of dissolve and,
and,
and be back to normal.
Um,
so you can,
you can test and you can say engage and,
and not being engaged.
We'll feel depression and anxiety.
So partly it's like you're trying to balance the mental health with the
cognitive health.
I mean you can't,
if you were to do cognitive rest for a month,
if you like being in solitary confinement and we know that that has really bad
mental health affects.
Right.
So,
um,
your kind of figuring this out as you go along,
there's really not a road map that's set out.
No one's ever done this before and you just sort of take your game designing
skills and apply what you know about the positive effects of games and you
experiment on yourself like a Guinea pig.
Yeah,
I was worried that you might be fucking your brain up or Nah,
I'm like
what could be worse than what was already happening.
Um,
and I mean,
I'll like literally within 48 hours the,
that fog that like super black,
you know,
you wanted,
I fog was gone and it was,
it none of the symptoms and go and it was as can cost as I was,
but that,
that feeling of hopelessness really went away.
And because of the fun of it.
So this is,
this is why I wrote the book because I didn't really understand why worked.
I knew it worked for me and then I put the rules online and people started
writing me from all over the world that they were using it.
And not just for concussions.
I mean,
people were writing for,
you know,
I have cancer,
I just had knee surgery.
Someone you know,
who was just like noticed with als starts playing it.
And uh,
um,
it,
it seems to be,
it seemed to be extraordinary effective at treating depression,
anxiety and also making people feel just stronger,
just like better of themselves.
And I did not understand it.
And this is,
I say this all the time people,
because there can be a lot of skepticism that a game can be helpful during a
really serious,
uh,
challenge in your life.
It sounds like trivial.
It sounds stupid.
Um,
so I freely acknowledged,
I didn't understand why it worked.
It seemed kind of absurd to me for people with much more serious problems and I
had to,
um,
so that's why I wrote the book.
It's why I started doing,
in our clinical trial and the studies we've been doing for the last few years to
try to understand because I didn't at all I knew was that it seemed to be having
all these positive effects and that,
uh,
that was,
it was,
I mean even to a game designer like myself who believes in the power of games,
I was really taken off guard.
Right.
So how did you structure it?
Like,
did you first start off just coming up with things like power pills or walnuts
and bad guys or depression and how did you like put this whole thing together?
Yeah,
I mean,
I just started making youtube videos,
which is really funny.
You can go back and look at like the first youtube videos of me.
It's like,
I don't think Scott,
like why I'm making a game for my concussion or something like that.
And First Youtube video you made,
what were you still suffering?
Oh yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
How many months was it into?
I thought this is like,
I think on day 34 this is like the day I'm like,
I'm making a game.
I'm going to make a youtube video explaining the game.
What's it like to when you watch that video now?
Oh,
it's crazy because I can't,
you can see,
I can't think of words.
Aye.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
What is it?
What would it be under?
Why I'm making a game?
Concussion,
something like that.
Jamie.
You'll find it.
Yeah.
Cause it's like you can see I can't,
I can't,
I mean,
you see how fast I talk.
Am I right?
I'm like talking.
Really.
So how long ago was this?
Five years ago?
Yeah.
And how long do you think it was before you felt like 100% you again?
I mean,
so I'm like 99% right now.
Maybe.
Yeah.
I mean there's still not 100%.
No,
there's the,
yeah,
there's still some things like certain lights.
I can't be around.
Like it's,
it creates,
it's like,
it feels like I'm having five years later.
Yeah.
Well let's,
let's play this real quick.
Okay.
I am making this video to explain and project some volume.
Jack hijacked a game to help the recovery process that I'm dealing with it after
I hit my head and got a concussion and that was about five weeks ago and their
recovery has been very slow and hard.
So,
um,
it's getting to a point where I feel like I need again to help me get what I was
doing some research today about post concussion syndrome,
which is what definitely told that weird artifacts and the sound will
concentrating trouble.
I mean,
I'm probably just sitting there with my laptop in my lap.
Um,
serious planning,
mental problem solving that would give me a concussion pickler and having a very
hard time.
I was not a pro.
Um,
and uh,
and I get dizzy a lot.
Um,
and I get headaches and nauseous,
that kind of thing.
It's definitely,
yeah.
Can really see clearly you're,
you're moving way,
way slower.
You're talking way slower.
You can see you're struggling.
No.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Unless you're on meth right now.
I am a naturally very energetic person.
It's fascinating to me that you're not 100% still.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know it and I'm not sure entirely why I was knocked out once when I was
younger,
like knocked out for like five minutes.
Um,
what happened?
I fell off a sliding board.
What's a sliding?
I feel like a Philadelphia thing.
I don't know.
Uh,
like a slide like,
uh,
like at the playgrounds that you go down there.
Oh,
fried chicken Philly.
We called it sliding boards and I fell right off the side and hit my head on a
cement block.
Oh yeah.
That's what I was really young.
That was my first concussion.
So that's probably
what's going on to,
as it were,
repeated concussions,
right?
No,
no.
What's interesting is I was so young,
I did not,
I was like,
I don't know if it's like four or something.
I actually didn't know that I'd had a concussion.
I thought this was my first concussion in 2009.
And the doctor's like,
oh,
have you had a concussion port?
No.
Um,
because obviously everyone knows now if you have more than one,
it can start to,
the healing will take longer.
I didn't know until like a month into my injury,
I'm talking to my parents and they mentioned,
well,
you know,
the last time you had a concussion you were feeling better and much faster.
And I'm like,
what?
What,
what last time?
Oh,
you remember when you fell off the sliding board when you were,
you know,
anything when there were four.
I know,
uh,
my five year old doesn't remember anything when she was four.
No.
Like,
you know,
when you broke your collarbone,
I'm like,
oh,
I do remember like wearing a sling for collarbone,
but I didn't know that I had a concussion.
So,
uh,
so even though you were four and then the next one,
you were an adult.
It's still
maybe,
I mean,
it's,
I,
eh,
people like Reese,
the fines does not quite understand how this works yet.
Like if,
if the cumulative Knox have to be all within the same few years or if it can
stretch out over a lifetime.
I try not to think about it too much because I'm like,
you know,
God,
if it happens again that I'm really,
you know,
but I'm actually,
I like walk around like this covering yeah,
give,
I'm,
if I'm at like at a,
you know,
like a concert or like in a 200 a element.
I literally want,
if I'm like at a nightclub or something,
I want to wear a helmet.
I'm like wondering if I can bring that back.
I stayed a girl that used to go to mosh pits.
It was crazy.
And uh,
she got headbutted by a dude once she came over to my apartment after she,
uh,
had been marching and she's like holding her head and I'm like,
what do you deal with?
I think she went to see some crazy fucking bad,
I'm trying to remember the,
is there a band called the creeps?
It was,
yeah,
it was in Boston and like 88 89.
So we should be wearing helmets.
You definitely don't get headbutted in a mosh pit.
Yeah.
But I would think like there's certain assholes like drunken dummies and you'd
go out to places you,
you know,
no.
And I'm short,
so I'm always worried about the elbows.
Someone's like reaching for something,
some big dude.
We'll just,
I mean,
even like on planes when people are taking down their luggage,
I like cower by the windows or by the window.
Smart.
Yeah.
That's um,
the,
the recognition of vulnerabilities,
uh,
an issue with people that get hurt because then all of a sudden you realize you
can get hurt and sometimes you just walk on eggshells all the time.
It reduces the quality of your life.
Exactly.
And that's,
I mean,
that's sort of,
that gets to that idea of,
you know,
spotting the bag eyes,
things that could hurt you and then you decide kind of how,
how comfortable you are.
You can't just run away.
You can't just hide.
You have to kind of push your comfort limits a little bit.
Um,
so I'm not going to go skiing.
I that ski ski.
Yeah.
Wow.
I didn't think certain.
There's certain things now that I feel like it's not worth the risk to me.
A third,
you know,
I can only imagine.
I just started skiing at 45.
It's my first time skiing.
I fucking wiped out hard last year,
but that's fine.
Just,
and didn't hit my head and I'm pretty good at falling.
I know how to fall or Tom molden rolled with it,
but I was like,
dude,
I was going to fast when I wiped.
Oh yeah,
there's a video that's online too.
We retweeted earlier today.
This fucking kid is in Colorado and he's on a skateboard and he's going 70 miles
an hour down a hill and you just watch it.
And like every part of my body's like tingling with fear,
you know,
that anticipation injuries.
Just,
you tweeted that.
Did you treat the roof topper?
Like the guy in Russia?
So,
you know,
I'm really interested in like neuro hacks,
how you can do little things to like change,
like how your brain is working right now.
Um,
and that video,
it seemed to me would be really good for people to get a little bit of
adrenaline going.
If you're like on your couch and you're like having a hard time getting yourself
out of bed.
Oh my God,
he's going 70 miles an hour down this crazy hill
with horrible music and it looks like a video game.
Right?
I mean,
it's just crazy that this kid is doing this because you can't stop.
actually,
he's really good.
Yeah.
So there's a point where he,
uh,
he turns a skateboard sideways to slow it down,
like at the very,
uh,
but,
and there's a couple little wiggles there.
It looks like he's about to go down.
And if he goes down,
dude,
you're breaking everything.
Oh yeah.
You're going 70 miles an hour.
I mean,
he is fall lying.
There's no way.
I mean,
they're not faking this unless this is some sort of advanced CG.
No,
I was going to say,
I mean,
it almost could be a video game.
Like watch when he reaches his hands down,
he has some kind of crazy gloves on and when he reaches his hands down,
there's certain parts in the video where he's a touching the sparks,
sparks the sparks.
I look at that.
Jesus fucking Christ,
I cried.
He almost fell.
I mean he's getting like really close to falling.
Like there's a couple times there where there's like this intense wiggle and
he's talking himself like a,
a speed skater so that he can go faster.
Yeah.
Crazy fucker.
Like what is wrong with kids?
I mean I get it.
This is an adrenaline rush.
But when you see this knowing what you suffered from standing up under a
cabinet.
Yeah.
And does this freak?
Does he have a helmet on?
Is that a hat?
That's a helmet.
It's a helmet.
Held him.
Was that how long are going to do well?
Oh little.
We get legal.
You this,
look at that.
That kid is crazy.
That's how he slowed down and now he's up.
He's down to a reasonable pace.
But when you see him,
he'll do it again to slow it down.
He grabs a board and look at this.
That is nuts.
Are you figuring out how many hours have,
I mean cause he's like a virtuoso at.
Yeah.
So there's like thousands and thousands of hours.
He's put the 10,000 hours in.
Yeah.
But good Lord,
when you see something like that,
no one what you went through,
like anything like when you see like dirt bike riders
doing fine.
I actually have a really,
I stopped watching professional football,
um,
after I used to,
you know,
I mean go 40 niners right.
But,
uh,
I can't,
I can't watch football anymore.
Like I just,
I mean,
I can,
but,
uh,
I don't enjoy it in the same way because I,
I just feel,
I feel bad players and when I see,
when I see like a really hard hit,
I just,
I just feel bad.
So
I think that's something a lot of people are struggling with these days with all
these,
you know,
the real sports story that they did on traumatic brain injury and the issues
that people are having and the,
all the stuff that I've seen from fighters over the years is,
it's definitely affected my enjoyment.
What's this retiring after concussion next hit to my head.
Could possibly,
wow.
I mean,
this is a thing now,
right?
Three,
four,
yeah.
They're,
they're retiring one,
two years into their career.
Yeah.
Well,
there's more of that now than ever before because guys are realizing first of
all,
at the end of,
uh,
at the end of their career,
they're most likely going to be debilitated.
Yeah.
I mean,
almost all of the players that take a lot of hits suffer from serious injuries
for the rest of their lives.
Yeah.
And so when you're young and you're looking at your future,
go and look,
I could put all my energy into this and you know,
be a mess.
Or I can say,
you know what,
I'm still young.
I'm 23.
I could do anything I want.
Like,
look,
I've been in the NFL,
I've,
I've experienced it.
Let me just get the fuck out of here.
Yeah.
Go try something else.
She worried that the future of the sport is going,
there's going to be a big socioeconomic divide.
We're the only people who,
who really want to play and are willing to take that risk are people who feel
like they have nothing to lose.
You know,
um,
we just stat and there's the people that want to watch it.
Like we,
we've experienced that with the UFC too.
There's a,
there's a bunch of people that want to watch the,
the head injuries that just,
they don't know what they're seeing yet.
They don't understand.
Like when you,
you watch somebody get kol like really badly,
when you see someone get head kicked or no dropped in their head or something
like that,
you,
you just see excitement.
He still like,
oh,
that guy just beat that guy.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
I know.
And I,
it's,
uh,
yeah,
I can't watch,
I can't watch fights either for the same reason when I have friends who are so
into it and,
you know,
you just,
because I mean so,
right.
I Love Games.
I understand a good game.
Good,
good sport is a good game.
Um,
and,
uh,
you admire people's ability to be so good at this.
You know,
this thing that we've created to test human potential.
But,
um,
but you know,
if I've sort of started drifting to sports where there's fewer concussions,
although,
you know,
like I'm a big tennis fan and one of the big stars just got a concussion this
weekend at the u s open,
so she slipped,
uh,
in the,
in like the locker room after doing like the ice bath after like,
uh,
um,
and,
uh,
it's interesting they showed her coming to the courts to see if she could
practice with her sunglasses on the hoodie pulled up and she just has that,
that look that like now I saw her,
I was like,
oh my God.
I mean,
she's like right in that zone of where she thinks she's going to play because
she's not thinking clearly,
but you can see her.
I mean,
she's like a shell of herself.
Um,
so when you see something like that,
do you want to reach out?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
No,
I know.
And people have been tweeting at her to be like,
you have to get super better,
you know,
finish their clinical trial.
You could,
I know,
be better,
but what is super better,
right.
Yeah.
Uh,
I do,
I do want to reach out because,
um,
because I know how hard it was and how,
how so few people,
I mean just the,
the general public conversation about this is not caught up to kind of the
reality of what people experience
well that uh,
those ice baths,
that's a,
one of the problems with that,
that form of cold therapy is that you get out in your legs like rubber.
Yes.
You're,
everything's not working so good.
That's why you can't do that stuff and then work out.
Right.
You know,
to some forms of cold therapy that you can do and you can work out after it,
but not those ice pass.
I have done,
I run marathons.
I have done some ice bath and I've,
yeah,
I,
have you ever done the whole body cryotherapy?
We stepped in the chamber and you go to 250 degrees below zero for three
minutes.
It's awesome.
Oh,
it's the best body element.
Like do you kind of,
is there like a mental state that is changed?
Oh yeah.
Well,
your brain produces something called neoprene,
Nefron,
cold shock proteins and all these different things happen when you hit minus one
50 degrees below zero.
Yeah.
It's,
there's also the something that someone just invented,
one of the reserve brought this up,
something called a cryo helmet.
Like you put it on over your head.
It's like a gel pack thing.
Like a,
it's almost like a Hoodie and you put it on and it's like they,
they really recommend it for people that have had head injuries,
sort of reduction in swelling.
Right.
I could,
I mean I could see that if you're trying to treat the inflammation.
Yeah.
Because it's like a whole thing.
Like I got like a frozen helmet,
you know,
he goes a little gel packs.
I took one of those.
But it's a helmet on your head.
I will of course I'm going to say no.
You got to pull up like Google scholar though.
For me,
I want to see like is there any literature on this yet?
Um,
cause I'm,
so I'm like hold up.
I don't pull it.
I'm fairly conservative with telling other people what to do.
Like for myself,
you know,
I was like,
oh,
I'll make a game.
But for telling other people to do,
I'm like,
wait until there's a peer reviewed paper for sure.
But fighters,
you know,
bas Rutten who's a former UFC heavyweight champion,
great fighter was talking about that.
That's a,
that's important.
Like when guys get hit to ice their head after it's over,
and he in his rationale was like,
look,
if you hurt your knee,
what's the first thing they do?
They put ice on it.
Why don't you put ice on your head?
I was like,
that actually makes a lot of sense.
Yeah,
I know,
that's really interesting.
I was just reading about,
you know,
you probably know this,
they say like five minutes after you stopped breathing,
supposedly you have like brain cell death.
Have you heard this?
If somebody who's drowned and you can't get them breathing again in five
minutes,
um,
then supposedly it's too late and they're now finding that if you cool down the
body and the brain that they can come back.
You can be not breathing,
not,
you know,
heart,
heart beating for more than five minutes.
Now if you get the body temperature so enough,
pack them with ice.
That's what they're doing now they're starting to do that.
It's like a first,
uh,
I know,
and I was like,
I was just telling my husband,
I'm like,
we need to,
we need you to read this literature.
So cause I want to know if I'm supposed to do this or wait until like the EMT
shows how,
like if something happens,
should I start packing ice or,
yeah.
I'm not sure.
Uh,
I'm not actually sure if the practical implications of this.
As you get older you realize more and more hell damn vulnerable people are so
physically vulnerable.
Yes.
Well this is really interesting because you know,
I,
in doing what I do,
I have confronted a lot of skepticism and I would even say,
I mean people who are really quite sarcastic,
but they hear about this,
Oh,
I'm going to adopt a secret identity.
It's going to make me not depressed.
You know,
usually it's people not suffering from depression who say this.
Cause if you're really suffering from something debilitating,
like clinical depression,
you will try anything.
So the people who are pretty happy and healthy and they'll,
they'll say this,
it sounds ridiculous.
Um,
but,
but you're talking about bloggers,
right?
Yeah,
it's,
well,
yeah.
And The New Yorker just ran a big giant piece,
uh,
about,
about super better,
um,
uh,
sort of,
you know,
it was both positive but also like still this sounds kind of ridiculous.
Well it does sound ridiculous,
but then it's like,
oh,
can work and sound ridiculous.
Exactly.
And that's why it's like,
I,
uh,
when you realize how vulnerable people are and how much is out of our control,
I mean those are the people who are the first in line to try this and who
benefit the most.
So we had half a million people play an electronic version,
like logging their power ups and they're bad guys and quest so that I could get
data on it and see what are the most effective power ups.
Like how often do you have to,
you know,
check in to,
to get better.
And we found that people with the,
which is the most painful and difficult situations where the ones that were
benefiting the most,
it's like sort of the more you realize how vulnerable you are,
the more open you are and the more this kind of concrete,
purposeful,
positive action can actually make a big difference.
That makes sense.
I mean,
once you feel the vulnerability you,
you,
cause it'd be,
it becomes real.
Whereas when you look at someone who has a broken leg and you go,
oh,
I can intellectually understand that that person broke their leg,
but I don't know what it feels like.
Right.
You know,
if you've never broken your leg,
you don't know that feeling.
You're like,
ah,
fuck,
I can't even stand on this stupid thing.
Is that,
that feeling where like,
okay,
now what?
What do I have to do?
Tom would have to do,
and then the reality changes.
Yeah.
And the reality of you having that head trauma and trying to figure out like,
there's gotta be a way to get out of the swamp,
this mental swamp.
And I'm stuck in a let's fucking make a game.
Like let's do it.
You like you're just,
I mean,
it makes sense to me.
It be a person has been through a bunch of surgeries and injuries and stuff.
It totally makes sense to me because there's a reality that every time I've
really badly injured myself,
like where I needed knee surgery or something,
there's like a,
just an acceptance just goes,
Huh,
let's just go do it.
Let's go do it because now this thing's broken.
And until that happens,
there's a bunch of people will tell you,
well,
once you try rehabbing it,
why don't you try doing this?
Like,
no,
it's like,
I don't think you get it.
No.
And a lot of times you'll have an injury and you won't know if it will get
better.
Um,
W W if you'll be able to get back to what you were doing before,
which is actually where the name super better comes from because I wasn't sure I
would ever have the same cognitive capabilities I had.
And I,
at that time,
I was using,
you know,
I was,
I had just gotten my phd,
I was doing research.
I was,
you know,
I was to being able to have an intellectual profession.
Um,
and so I,
everyone's like,
get better soon.
And I'm like,
well,
what does that mean?
That means get back to who you were before this happened.
And I didn't know if I would ever be able to do any of that again.
So I thought,
well,
I'm not going to get better.
I'm going to get super better.
I'll just be different.
I'll be like this new super version of myself,
like Spiderman.
Uh,
you know,
he got bit by the radioactive spider and this concussions,
my radioactive spider,
and I don't know who I'm going to be,
but it'll be someone different.
And,
uh,
and instead of just trying to,
you know,
because anytime you're having an injury or an illness,
you don't know who you're going to be at the end of it.
He might be back to normal.
It might be different and you want it to be the best different that it could be.
Yeah.
There's been many stories of people that have gotten knocked in the head and all
of a sudden had musical house mathematical talent.
Yeah.
What are you hoping that that was going to
the weirdest experience?
Um,
so I'm a very introverted person by nature.
I,
you know,
like if my phone rings,
I won't answer it.
Like even if you're my friend or like your mind mom,
like,
oh,
it's too much social interaction.
Like I get anxiety,
I can't answer it.
So,
uh,
that's been like my whole life.
But,
um,
we,
what we know about,
like the difference between introverts and extroverts,
introverts tend to stimulate themselves with internal thinking.
They're always,
they're always thinking and they don't need other people to kind of get them
excited.
Extroverts respond much more positively to external stimulation.
It's like a,
it's like they're just primed.
If they see someone smiling at them,
it's like a cocaine hit,
you know.
So when I had the injury I couldn't think to myself anymore.
I couldn't like entertain myself with my own thoughts.
And I became like this super extroverted person and I started like calling
everybody in my phone,
like contact lists in which people I would never,
I mean we wouldn't even pick up the phone and I'm like,
please talk to me cause I couldn't,
I couldn't literally cannot be an introvert anymore.
But that only lasted for like a couple months and then my surgeon to get better.
I went back to being introverted and I still,
today I,
I try to keep some of that because I actually discovered,
wait,
I,
I really like,
it's nice to talk to people.
He does not actually a burden,
you know,
but,
but that's,
so that was,
that was,
that was one of the sort of super better,
you know,
changes for me is I realize and they were,
we know from psychological literature,
extroverts really are happier.
They live longer,
they're psychologically healthier.
It is,
if you can convince yourself to be social,
it's,
it's really good for you.
Um,
the introverts just so have a different brain chemistry.
So their brains telling them,
yeah,
two people scary.
Like,
you know,
too much stimulation.
Uh,
yeah.
Well that's the,
one of the weirdest things about online interaction is it,
it's kind of a combination of both introvert behavior and extrovert bay.
Cause even though you are interacting with people,
you're not seeing no,
it's controlled
and that's,
it's,
it's the face to face can be really a daunting.
Yeah.
Like you'd like the,
just the,
the energy that it takes.
Yeah.
I mean it's not,
it's not the same thing as being,
I mean,
just cause you're introvert doesn't mean you're,
I dunno,
like socially unable.
Like,
you know,
you're not,
you're not a misfit.
Well,
obviously you,
you're very capable of keeping a regular conversation going.
Yes.
I mean,
you're done.
Then you can say you're an introvert,
but you're easily,
you know,
you're easy.
You,
you're,
you're like,
you're just talking.
No problems.
You're not,
yeah.
I've had some introverts on this podcast before,
and then it's obvious.
They're like,
everything's an effort.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's probably more of an effort for me than it looks.
Hmm.
But I think it's more of an effort for everybody then it looks,
maybe that's a good point.
Yeah.
I think that I'm just,
one of the issues with online interaction is that you don't see the people and
you know,
you just,
it's just like,
my intention is it's kind of ambiguous.
You know,
like you're write something or you put something out there and it's a,
it's not completely clear.
Like if you say something,
I get the tone.
I can tell if you're being sarcastic.
And I,
if,
uh,
if someone,
if you say something mean to me,
like we have to look at each other,
I'm like,
fucking really?
Yeah.
Like in this weird thing to it.
Whereas if you do that online,
there's like none of that.
Yeah.
I think that there's,
there's something very strange that's going on in our culture right now with so
many people spending a giant amount of their time only interacting with people
through text.
Absolutely.
Well that's one of the areas of research that I was diving into.
So,
you know,
cause I don't just know research brain injury stuff,
I typically research video games and how they change how we feel and think and
act.
And what does that mean you're punched in?
The field is called performance studies.
So I was just basically studying how people perform,
um,
in video games and as a result of video games,
sort of collaboration skills,
they're sort of psychological performance,
um,
things like that.
At,
at Uc Berkeley it was where I studied.
And uh,
so one of the things that we know that's happening in video games is that
there's a really big difference between playing a video game in the same room
with somebody and playing online.
And so like if we're playing call of duty and I'm trying to kill you and if
we're playing in the same room,
we actually undergo really great,
uh,
it was kind of,
they call it synchronization.
So our heart rates,
we'll sync up our breathing rates,
sing GAAP,
we get it's kind of mirror neuron in process going on where it's like blood flow
is mirroring where it's flowing.
The patterns of activation are mirroring each other and all of that is
associated with more compassion,
more empathy.
We like each other more.
We trust each other more,
even if the game is violent,
even if we're competing.
Um,
all of this happens and it happens because,
you know,
when you were playing a game with or against someone,
you have to try to get in their brain like what are they going to do next?
What's next?
Move.
Um,
and so your brain starts to mirror what you think they're doing.
So it's this,
it's this really intense mind body mirroring that goes on.
What triggers the mirroring,
the observance of the character on the screen?
Uh,
well,
no,
it's,
it's because it only works if you're in the same space,
physical space with them,
but you're still looking at a screen.
Yeah.
Well you're trying to think what are they doing?
And there just something about if you're the,
you may think you're looking at the screen,
but there's also a general awareness,
like when you're sitting next to someone,
right,
you're aware of sort of what's going on and the,
and cues that you're picking up,
body language cues.
And if you'd like turn to look at them,
you'll even just in a split second,
you'll get this sort of facial expression queue.
Um,
and that doesn't happen in online games.
so what we've just been measured.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So what we've seen is if you take the same game and play it,
you know,
against somebody in the room,
you wind up with these positive impacts,
uh,
like,
you know,
more compassion,
more empathy.
You like each other more.
If you play the same game online,
you're not able to see their facial expression.
You're not able to get the same,
uh,
sinking phenomenon.
You actually dehumanize the opponent,
you,
your testosterone goes up,
you feel less empathy towards them.
Um,
and so it's one of the reasons why in the book I talk about how,
you know,
unless you're actively trying to change your personality to be more aggressive
and you want to,
I don't know,
for some reason you feel like you want to be kind of more of a have,
it's like aggressive,
hostile personality.
A,
you should not spend more than half your time trying to beat strangers online
because of the,
because it's just not
after times,
a lot of time,
half your half your gaming time.
Oh Jesus Christ.
What are you recommending?
24 hours in a day?
No more than 12 hours.
Killing strangers.
And it actually,
yeah,
21 hours a week is where you start to see the benefits of games reduce and
negative impacts increase.
So there's another public service announcement.
Um,
what have you,
have you done it in layers where you know,
you like I used to do a land parties.
My friends used to play quake lan parties.
Um,
and it's really fun.
You know,
there's a lot of camaraderie and stuff.
Yeah.
But if you put a barrier up,
yeah.
But during the same room or if they're in a room that's right next door,
but you know they're there and may be can hear their voice or if you shut that
door and you can't hear their voice,
have you changed?
Have they seen like what,
what if the mirroring is consistent?
Yeah.
I'm the studies that I've seen show that you have to be in physical proximity.
So if there was a barrier and we were unable,
I was unable to look over and get those cues from your body language or from
your facial expression that it would not happen.
How'd your cubicle thing and I can just like reach up.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Then you,
then you probably would,
I like,
I liked this idea of this aging.
The thing I'm really curious about is with twitch and now youtube gaming is if
you can watch somebody playing and,
and now you're seeing their face,
um,
while they're playing a game.
Um,
studies have shown that watching someone play a game that you know how to play
will trigger the same mirror neurons because your brain can kind of emulate,
uh,
if you're playing a game,
I don't know how to play.
I don't know if the controls,
I don't know the goals.
My brain will just be like,
I don't know.
Right.
If I know how to play the game,
like,
oh,
I know what she's trying to do.
I know what a strategist.
Yeah.
Whatever it is,
everybody knows what to do,
can away from the ghost.
Yeah.
So one thing I'm interested in is if I can see someone's face,
you know,
while they're playing the game,
they're playing a game.
I know,
could you get some of the benefits,
but it would only be uni directional because if you're like live streaming your
game plan,
you can't see me.
So,
uh,
but it would be interesting since we know that if you get this mirror neuron a
fact,
um,
it makes people want to help each other more like each other more.
I'm like thinking like being a powerful,
you know,
twitch streamer or youtube game streamer like could make you really cultivate a
large community of people who really want to help you,
which put seems like,
like if I were building an empire of like a new kind of community,
I feel like that would be what I would be building because they would be really,
um,
it would be like a really tight bond,
you know?
That's fascinating.
You know,
this twitch thing has caught a lot of people by surprise because I think a lot,
no one would have ever thought that it would be so popular to watch someone play
video games.
Right.
And the mirror neuron thing helps explain it because it's not like watching TV
where it's just passive.
If you know how to play the game,
your brain starts working to sort of process it and anticipate,
you know,
what they're gonna do next.
Trying to figure out what has,
what decision lawmaker or where they'll go.
Um,
and so you're actually getting a lot of the same stimulation as if you were
playing the game yourself.
And that's the thing people don't understand.
Um,
we see this with musicians too.
If you know how to play a musical instrument and you watch somebody playing that
same musical instrument,
your brain starts to,
you know,
activate as if you are playing it yourself,
which is why it can be more interesting for,
you know,
somebody knows how to play the piano,
to watch someone else play the piano or listen to someone else play the piano
versus somebody who doesn't know.
That totally makes sense.
When a,
I used to play quake,
we used to watch these uh,
things.
Uh,
they were,
they call them demos and what it was was a game that they would record.
Yeah.
And so you'd see it through a player's eye,
so you get to see how good a player moves and then it would make you play
better.
You would do,
would play better after you saw that.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
They were really popular.
Like demos were super popular.
You would download them and you would play them in game like in your game.
Yeah,
I remember that.
Yeah.
Do you remember that?
I was like into counter strike a little bit.
Well that's the case with athletics too.
Um,
a lot of people tell me that when they watch like a really good basketball
player play that it makes them play better basketball.
Yep.
I know it's the case with pool.
I played pool and when I watch really good players play,
like I can kind of emulate what they do.
But if I feel like it's not just like copying,
but I kind of tune in.
Oh yeah,
they're good
because your brain is practicing it.
I,
I find that after a grand slam in tennis,
it was because I'll watch me only reason why I'm not watching tennis right now
is because we're here doing this.
I like something going on.
I had the u s open,
my favorite player is playing like literally right now in your player Joe Willie
Tsonga who I named my puppy after.
I have a dog named the Songa if he's playing right now to get,
get to the semis.
Um,
but no spoilers because I'm recording it.
but I know that,
so I'll go like two weeks watching hours and hours of tennis a day.
Then I go to play tennis and I'm better.
I'm absolutely,
I,
I see the ball better,
I get to it better.
Um,
I'm absolutely,
She,
because my brain has spent two weeks mirroring everything.
I see.
But if you don't know how to play,
if you've never played,
your body won't do it.
So you have to have,
you have to have a model for,
for this to work.
Totally makes sense.
Yeah.
Because like something like tennis,
like I've maybe played once in my whole life when I was in my early twenties,
so you wouldn't get as much benefit.
I wouldn't get anything because I'm not going to play again.
I don't think.
I just don't have time in the day.
But I,
I totally understand that.
That totally makes sense.
I think that probably is the case with pretty much everything that people do.
It's one of the reasons why,
uh,
a sense of community amongst people that are all involved in the same sort of
endeavor.
So important because you kind of push each other and inspire each other and also
you kind of feed off of each other.
Maybe one,
like if we were all comedians,
maybe you would have like a certain kind of style that I don't have and I would
see your style go,
oh,
Jane's got this crazy thing she's doing well,
that's Kinda cool.
And then like maybe I would do something that you didn't do and you're like,
maybe I need to like be more this or me more and sort of tune into how people
are doing to the point where a lot of comics when they're around each other,
um,
it becomes an issue sometimes because they kind of mimic each other's personas
or,
or maybe just the cadence.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Start picking up.
Well,
there's a guy named David towl.
It's like one of the funniest guys ever.
And uh,
he's got a way of talking that's really fun.
And when he talks,
like there's so many young guys that come up that star talking like Dave a towel
and it's like,
it became an issue where there was like all these little,
like Patrice O'Neal Eastcom tell babies.
There was all these,
uh,
tell babies that were running around it.
But it really,
they're just young comics that admire is sorta Kate in.
They're trying to do it too.
And they were like super inspired because they're young and they're just trying
to make it,
and then to seeing this guy who's this,
you know,
like fantastic comedian,
like,
and then they don't even realize it,
but they're just adopting it.
Yeah.
No,
that makes perfect sense.
I mean,
you just,
uh,
it becomes a template.
Yeah.
Nobody exists in a vacuum.
Right?
I mean,
everybody sort of,
there's the,
everyone influences everyone around to a certain extent.
We all want to believe that we're some rogue independent operator that exists
out in the fringe of society and lives in a fucking wooden house in the woods
somewhere.
That sounds nice.
It sounds nice,
but it's a,
it's a k it's a creation of fiction.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
no,
and it's funny,
I some of the um,
uh,
someone I admire,
Clive Thompson,
he writes a lot about technology for like wired and your times.
Um,
and he had a book out recently about,
you know,
is technology changing our brain.
And the opening chapter says,
you know,
newsflash,
everything changes your brain.
This sentence you just read,
it changed your rain.
Right?
So I mean on one hand it's sort of silly to look at research that says,
Oh,
games change your brain like this or you know,
music changed everything like that.
Um,
because everything you do,
everything you're exposed to changes your rain and you're making a memory or
your,
your sort of activating a pattern.
Um,
so I mean like even this conversation,
you know,
congratulations like you have changed my brain today,
but this is just something to think about,
like a lot of responsibility and I know how we interact with each other.
Yeah.
It is.
And,
well,
that's one of the weirdest things about doing a podcast is how many people will
tell me after they listened to podcasts for our 500 episodes,
dude,
you changed my life.
Oh yeah.
Good.
It's a lot of responsibility,
but we really are changing each other's lives.
I mean,
the podcast has changed my life.
Just being able to talk to all these different people.
It's why it's important not to have dip shits and your life.
Because if you're around people that are just constantly fucking up and
constantly making the same mistakes over and over again,
like that pattern affects you too.
Yeah.
That pattern will creep into your mind.
Yes.
Well then say,
you know,
it's,
it's really good to try and yourself with people who inspire you because they,
they talk about having a cognitive model for behavior change.
Like if you're trying to get better in some way,
uh,
if you can visually,
if you know somebody who's already done it or doing positive things in their
lives,
it's,
it requires less energy for your brain to imagine yourself doing it.
Like,
if you're,
if you don't,
if you're not trying to be anybody who's trying to get healthy or trying to get
fit or whatever it is,
um,
it's like,
it's literally harder to imagine.
And so it's like more exhausting for you to try to imagine yourself getting
better.
Whereas if you're surrounded by people who are doing it,
it becomes familiar to your brain.
There's all sorts of examples that your brain can call on.
It literally takes less energy for you to imagine yourself actually doing it.
And weirdly,
they found at Stanford University using,
uh,
like avatars.
If you can see an Avatar that is designed to look like you,
like doing the sort of things you want to do,
like,
you know,
being really physically fit,
like working out in the game world.
If you just watch an avatar customer design to look like you doing that,
it lowers the cognitive threshold for you to do it.
And then you will do more in real life.
You leave,
you know,
you will work out more or you'll spend more time committed to those goals just
by having watched the sort of mirror version of yourself having done it.
That's fascinating that,
that's fascinating because that seems to open up a whole new of possibility for
people creating virtual realities.
Yeah.
Like virtual realities where you're,
what,
like one of the big things that they say it's an important for progress in
sports and,
and in pretty much anything is visualization.
Visualize yourself doing things.
It's a big thing with martial arts.
They,
uh,
take a lot of fighters.
They,
they,
they talk them through their scenarios.
They've,
they will sit down and the close her eyes and meditate and visualize a
themselves getting out of bad situations,
visualize themselves winning and do it over and over and over again to the point
where it becomes like a part of this is your reality.
Your reality is you win.
Yeah.
You know,
it seems like if you could watch a video of you doing all those things and
artificially created you yup.
Absolutely.
Jumping higher than you've ever jumped before.
Did scoring and tennis or,
yeah.
So it's like,
it's,
there's a little bit of nuance to it that's really interesting.
So,
um,
for example,
if you are like walking on a treadmill while you're watching a custom avatar of
yourself and the Avatar,
you know,
starts running faster and is getting fitter,
you will run faster,
you will,
you will work harder.
If you are engaged in an activity,
it can really,
uh,
get you moving.
So it was like,
it would be good to tie it to when you're actually working out.
Like it might not be,
it might not last for,
you know,
I watched this movie today and a week later I'm still feeling more powerful.
You kind of want to do it in the moment.
Um,
are they the one study at Sanford found for 24 hours?
They were safe,
sort of,
were more physically active,
like taking stairs or doing more pushups or whatever.
Um,
but uh,
but I do like the idea of using it perfectly like that.
The one thing they know is like for positive visualization,
I don't know if you've seen,
there's been new research coming out that you have to visualize the effortful
action and not the outcome.
Like if you're visualizing getting,
you know,
lifted up on people with people shoulders,
like I'm the champion.
Um,
that actually seems to sometimes have a counter productive effect because your
brain can imagine it so vividly.
You kind of feel like you've already had that payoff and your,
you put in less effort that does ms studies for a few years at show this.
Um,
so,
uh,
but if you're visualizing the effortful activity that it takes to get there,
you're picturing,
you know,
here's what I have to do on game day and you're thinking about,
um,
the,
the things that require effort on your part techniques or you know,
the actions you're going to take.
Um,
that is helpful.
So you just don't want to think about,
you know,
I can't wait til they,
call me up and say that I won.
Right.
Whatever you have,
you can't think about it.
Just,
you have to be visualizing the things that are going to require effort and
energy on your part.
That's the,
that's that seems to be the most help.
It's so fascinating because like just that statement right there,
that seems to be the most helpful.
There's so much weirdness and all this is so it's,
it's like magic.
Like what the fuck is going on?
Like what the,
with the visualization process,
what's the mechanism like what,
what,
what is it an inspiration?
I mean how much of inspiration,
how much is inspiration a factor in success?
I would say probably gigantic.
Right?
So is that all right?
I mean there's,
there's so many different avenues I am,
I focus on self efficacy as what you're trying to increase.
Uh,
as opposed to inspiration.
So self efficacy is when you feel like you have the skills and abilities and
resources you need to achieve your goal.
And it's,
it's,
it's different from self esteem.
Self esteem is like,
Oh,
I'm a good person United.
Sort of like myself.
Self efficacy is very specific.
Like,
if I have self efficacy about running a marathon,
it means that I have done and you know,
at least a few 20 mile runs.
I know how hard it's going to be.
I've got my receipt,
I know how to,
you know,
fuel during the Ron.
I know how much I hate to take sodium.
I have to take a different points.
I know what the course looks like,
so I've got a mental plan.
Having that sense of reasonable optimism and focusing on visualizing what you'll
do successfully that's focused on your own skills and abilities that in all of
the scientific literature is linked to better outcomes.
Whereas if you're imagining things that are outside of your control,
it just doesn't because how is it might inspire you and maybe you'll,
you know,
get out of bed and put more of an effort as you,
picture something good happening to you.
But the,
the mental model that seems to be most powerful is when you're focusing on
things that you have direct control over,
if that makes sense.
Yeah.
The self efficacy.
Well,
how much of all that is just a little,
what you were talking about is just focus is just thinking about what you're
doing and the more you think about what you're doing and the more energy you put
towards what you're doing makes you better.
And how much of this is just mean?
Is it possible that all these ideas of just visualization is what you're doing
is really just focusing more and loving more what you're doing?
I think that could be a big part of it.
I mean,
the,
the focus attention it,
you're,
you're able to perform better,
you learn faster.
I think part of it is also something to do with the dopamine system.
Um,
you know,
in video games.
So if some,
so I've talked to lots of neuroscientists,
um,
for this book and um,
a lot of them will say if you wanna increase someone's self efficacy,
you have them play a video game.
Because I'm in a video game,
you're constantly required to take action and then wait to see,
you know what,
I try to fire my weapon.
I wait to see if I shot successfully.
I try to orient around an obstacle,
I'm going to see,
I'm going to get information every time that your brain expects information
about your performance,
it gives you a little dopamine release and dopamine feels good.
So you got excited.
Um,
but increased open mean also allows you to pay closer attention and to learn
faster,
right?
So anytime you're trying something where you're constantly taking actions,
getting feedback and you have to kind of learn and improve,
uh,
you'll get all this dopamine going and that is associated with the ability to
build self efficacy.
So I think that there is a,
I mean,
I think there's a neurochemical process that's underlying this.
It's not,
it's not just,
um,
I mean it's not just a matter of,
of what you think.
It's also about changing what is going on in your brain so that the brain is
primed to learn faster to improve.
And that's um,
that's,
um,
that's why,
you know,
that's why there seemed to be so many cool applications for video games because
if you can get a cancer patient who feels really powerless and overwhelmed to
play a video game about chemotherapy and it starts building self advocacy and
getting all the dopamine going,
there was a clinical trial that showed that kids who played a video game about
cancer,
we're for two to three months later missing fewer doses of their medicine,
taking more antibiotics,
they were more engaged,
um,
which leads to more cases of cancer being going into remission.
Right?
But isn't that just more focus?
Just focusing and thinking,
man,
it's using it as a mechanism to focus and think about your illness,
focus and think about your recovery.
It's focused with the dopamine hit and the increased over mean is gonna it,
it,
it changes what's,
well now we'll get really deep here.
Um,
every time that you consider a goal,
your brain stops and says,
is it worth it?
Because your brain is trying to conserve your body's energy and you know,
they're the,
your cognitive energy.
And we'll say,
if I,
if I do this goal,
am I,
do I really want it?
Am I going to put the energy to do it?
And what researchers have found is the more dopamine you have in your reward
pathways,
the more you focus on the positive outcome and the less you think about the
effort required.
So if I give you a bunch of dopamine hits,
you're going to be thinking about,
I might be cured someday.
I don't care how many side effects there are to this medicine.
I'm swallowing this pill,
you know,
and,
and I'm going to do it because you're focused on the positive outcome,
not all of the other things that stress you out about it or make you,
you know,
the nausea and the,
the,
the energy that it takes.
And this is true if you're doing push ups,
you know,
like,
do I really feel like doing a hundred pushups right now?
Um,
if you have more dopamine going,
you're going to be more likely to say,
this is important to me.
It's part of my training.
Um,
and if you are low dopamine,
which is when you're clinically depressed,
you have really load open mean.
So everything seems too hard.
Oh,
why am I going to bother getting out of bed?
There's like the effort required seems so much more important than the goal.
So there is a neurological underpinning to self advocacy is sort of this
combination of really wanting to achieve your goal and having that increased
attention so you learn faster.
So there's,
but you have to,
it's,
I mean,
it's not,
it's not just a matter of saying,
I'm going to pay attention.
Now you have to be priming your brain to increase the dopamine and your reward
pathways.
Right?
But the dopamine hit.
What is the mechanism that creates the dopamine hit?
Is it just simply loving what you're doing,
you know?
No,
no,
no.
It's gold.
It's anticipation.
What specifically?
It's anticipation of feedback.
So the fastest way for like,
you want it to increase your dopamine right now,
I would say make a prediction about something that's going to happen today.
Um,
it could be anything.
I could,
I predict that song go,
we'll win today and four sets,
whatever it is.
You make a prediction about something.
Every time you make a prediction,
your brain's like,
oh,
I might be right.
I'm going to m n and that'll feel good.
And if I'm not right,
I'll learn something.
Why did he lose in five sites or whatever.
So I make a better prediction next time.
That gives you a dope me.
And so in a video game,
when you fire your weapon,
you have predicted that it's going to successfully shoot that guy over there and
you're waiting for to see on the screen.
Did I miss or did I hit?
That's why you get a dopamine hit.
So every time you make a prediction,
your brain jeers up to either celebrate that you were right,
Yay success or I got to learn so that I can do better the next time.
That's why I think I,
you know,
I have friends,
I have one friend in particular that didn't grow up with any healthy sense of
competition and it's,
he's actually talked about that.
Like if there's one thing that he could go back and do again,
like he thinks his parents didn't really instill any sense of competition in
him.
And he's one of those guys,
if he's playing a game,
it's not going his way.
He'll pull the plug.
Oh,
he'll flip the board over.
He's that guy.
Yeah.
Right.
Well,
you know what's going on in the brain.
So this is,
you have this reaction,
but to him losing is just devastating and write James or only if you can win.
Right.
Well,
and,
and it's probably what's going on.
It's his brain is saying,
you know,
it's starting to realize no amount of effort is going to turn this around.
And so he just walks away.
No,
there's no,
well,
not only that,
there's no,
there's no history of figuring things out and getting better.
Right.
Everybody who has ever started anything and gotten really good at it and knows
it in the beginning,
you suck.
And it's some,
it's kind of exciting.
Yeah.
Like,
um,
you,
you pick something up,
say a tennis,
you know,
like if I started to playing tennis today,
I don't know how to play tennis.
I would suck and it would be exciting because I would get my ass kicked on.
I'd be like,
okay,
I have to figure this fucking thing out.
Like what makes that ball spin like that?
How's that guy whacked that ball?
Oh,
I see.
He's,
no,
he knows he's number crunching.
He's gay.
He's like data.
He knows he's got,
he's chunking information.
He knows that if I move left,
the ball's going to go there and he's going to go here and,
Huh,
okay.
And I don't have that.
So,
and that experience of getting better,
I mean,
that's the basis for self efficacy.
Um,
so it's like,
sometimes people ask me,
like parents will say,
what kids should my,
what game should my kids be playing for a learning experience?
But I say every game is designed to be a learning experience because you're
supposed to be bad.
And that's why games feel so good is that you're,
you're,
every time you play a new game,
you're figuring it out.
You're learning how it works,
you're getting better.
That experience of constantly getting better and proving to yourself,
I can figure something out.
I can improve,
I can master something.
Um,
that's,
I mean that's one of the reasons this is a fundamental reason why people like
playing games and why they don't play the same game forever.
I mean sometimes you do if the game that you can never master like chess or
something,
you know,
but most people will,
will really get into a game for a while and then feel like they have stopped
improving.
And so the brain gets,
you know,
wants to keep learning,
wants to keep getting better.
The dopamine hits are only gonna come if you aren't sure how to be successful.
Right.
So you have to play a new game.
So why we don't play Tic Tac toe is adults,
right?
Nope.
No.
Dopamine hits from tic TAC toe.
Cause you know exactly what's going to happen.
Yeah.
Bullshit game and keep trying to tell my five year old,
it's going to be a draw every time kids bullshit.
Um,
but there's,
there's a,
a lead ism attached to chess.
Chess is the only game.
It's considered a,
a,
a worthwhile pursuing.
Now it's terrible.
What is that?
Because parents will tell kids that are playing video games and they're wasting
their time.
I know,
but if you came home when your kid was playing chess silently with his friend
and they're just looking at the,
he be like,
oh,
my kid is up to a good thing.
Okay,
sure.
I mean,
first because Einstein play chess so well,
I think that's part of it.
Although,
you know,
it's really interesting if you read letters that he used to write fucking hated
chess.
No,
he loved it.
But he wrote to people that he was worried that he was addicted to it.
He talked a lot about how,
how he had this game addiction,
which is fascinating when you think about today,
how many people worried about,
I'm addicted to world of Warcraft or whatever game.
So even Einstein worried about being addicted
to his favorite game.
It is real game addiction is absolutely real.
It is.
It is
a real,
um,
uh,
it is absolutely real.
And uh,
there are techniques for breaking that pattern by the way,
if you would,
do you want it quick technique for how to break?
Sure.
Okay.
There's a whole chapter in,
in the Super Better Book about the game addiction and how,
how to stop it,
how to reverse it.
Um,
and what tends to lead people into it.
Yeah.
Biggest that's my friend Duncan was on,
uh,
biggest addict I know to video games always have me feel normal.
Uh,
the biggest predictor for,
uhW,
who will become addicted to games and feel like it kind of gets out of control
spirals out of control is if they're playing for escapist purposes to try to
block other feelings.
Like,
I have these,
all these problems,
I'm going to play the game instead.
I'm,
I'm feeling anxious,
I'm going to play the game and said,
um,
so the way you reverse it is you,
you have to,
I mean,
I talk about it as playing to get better.
You are instead of playing to avoid something,
you focus on what you're doing that is making you better.
Even if it's just to start getting better at this game,
then you focus on,
you know,
why I'm playing with,
I,
my friends is like improving my relationships or I'm focusing on strategy or
building my teamwork skills or whatever it is.
You start to think about,
um,
other goals outside the game that the game is connected to because the
biological process of addiction is the narrowing of goals that the brain
responds to.
This is true for,
for drug addiction.
I mean,
all forms of addiction,
pornography,
narrowing of goals at the brain response,
right?
So,
you know,
I said,
you get like this dopamine hit.
When you anticipate something good in,
in addiction,
the brain starts to believe that the only source of the next dopamine hit is the
thing you're addicted to.
And you can't imagine other things that are gonna make you feel that good or
feel that excited.
And one of,
there's this great new book called the biology of desire that lays a
neuroscientist,
kind of lays out all the new thinking on addiction.
And the way that you break,
one of the ways you break out of cycle for any addiction is to start priming the
brain to anticipate success or pleasure from other things.
So you have to just talk about like widening the scope of what is going to
provide that dopamine hit.
So in game play you have to stop,
um,
you have to stop thinking about the game as the only source of that,
that,
that good feeling.
So you have to start thinking about other goals that you have besides just the
sort of sense of relief that the game is going to provide.
Um hmm.
So
that's something that they tell addicts that are drug addicts use channel at
addiction into something else.
So that's essentially what they're saying.
They're saying,
well,
you need to do is find something else,
but that's positive that you can get addicted to.
Yeah.
So you're seeking out that weird chemical reaction in the mind,
right.
When you're stimulated by something else.
Right.
And instead of chasing crack you'll chase exercise.
Yes.
But in what we're seeing with games,
because games aren't inherently dangerous,
you don't have to quit playing games.
And in fact it can be dangerous to just go cold Turkey on games because it's
like taking someone off an antidepressant without tapering them.
Because Games have such a powerful impact on our,
our happiness.
You know how the kids are going to listen to this go mom,
it's dangerous for me to quit this game.
[inaudible] Jane,
they're like suicide.
I mean their cases of kids who have killed themselves when their parents turn
off the game and those kids would have killed themselves over anything.
I I think,
I think it is likely related to,
it's the same thing when you take someone off and ended a precedent and the
brain is no longer having that.
Uh,
it's like dope.
You,
you,
you lose your ability to imagine.
Is the term it positive?
Is the term addiction?
Like is that a flawed term?
Like it,
cause it seems like it's so limited and so narrow in its scope.
We,
we think of addiction,
we think of always on the heroin,
you know,
like you just automatically think,
but really what is it that your brain has locked into these pathways of
achieving desirable effects?
Absolutely.
Um,
and that's,
there's a lot,
I've,
I've done some work with some real real rotation centers,
recovery centers for addiction where they're starting to be more aware of this,
the new sense of what addiction is.
Um,
but if people are interested,
the book that just came out this year about that the biology of desire does a
really good job of explaining it because it's,
I mean,
the,
it's a pretty provocative argument.
It says that addiction is not a disease.
It's,
it's a fun,
it's,
the brain is functioning absolutely perfectly.
It's just focusing on,
it's like hyper focusing on one goal.
But if you had that same brain chemistry about running a startup company,
I mean,
Mark Zuckerberg was addicted to his startup in the same way that someone can get
addicted to a video game or addicted to a substance,
you get hyper focused on one goal.
It's your only source of,
of pleasure and anticipation of,
um,
these positive feelings.
So it's,
the brain is working properly.
It's not broken.
It's not,
it's not a disease in that sense.
It's that,
uh,
it has just gotten stuck on a particular productive yeah.
That,
that is maybe ultimately not good for you physically are not good for your,
the life that you're trying to leave
career a good rest for your family life or,
yeah.
I had a buddy that was addicted to,
um,
one of those role playing games,
trying to,
I guess it was everquest and,
uh,
he,
he had this really profound statement we were at the comedy store wants,
he was one of the managers and uh,
he said,
I am so good at making money in my online life and so bad at it in my real life.
Yeah.
And like he was like,
he was sitting there like a broken man.
And I'm like,
how often?
He plays like eight hours,
nine,
10 hours a day.
Every day.
Yeah.
I go every day.
And he goes,
yeah,
I,
um,
I can't not play it.
And then that's when he said that like,
um,
it was like this rare break from the game on during his free time.
He wasn't working and he came down to the comedy store to hang out and he's
pasty white Pale like almost gray skinned.
Yeah.
Cause he was just like,
just drained mound Nurus sitting in front of a monitor all the time,
clicking and moving.
Right.
Yeah.
And so it's like the intervention for that,
you know,
if you were to sort of follow the guidelines,
uh,
of,
of how you try and get people to sort of focus on other goals is you would just
start by asking him,
well,
why are you good at making money in this game?
What,
what,
what does it take in terms of skill or commitment or reserve?
What are you,
what are you doing?
And,
and,
and start to think about strengths and abilities.
And then,
um,
when you are thinking about yourself and what you're good at and what you're
capable of,
it kind of takes you out of,
you own it.
It's not the game,
right?
The game isn't making you successful or happy.
It's your own skills and abilities.
And that seems to be,
if you look at the scientific literature,
just talking about what you own and what,
what is a result of your skills and abilities that that helps you broaden that.
So you realize you can apply that elsewhere.
There might be other venues.
It's not the game that's giving this to me and this is something that I own.
Right.
That's so hard to intellectualize.
Now when you're in the grips of addiction.
I know,
I know.
It's why this is just like questions in my book that like literally you can ask
someone or you can ask yourself so that you don't have to intellectualize it.
And we just do the,
so the,
there are a hundred quests in the book.
You just do what I do.
What I tell you to do.
They're all designed like little game missions.
Um,
because it is,
it is,
it is hard to change your mindset.
I mean,
it's definitely hard,
but what we know from studies of all kinds of mindset interventions is that once
you do it,
it sticks.
So unlike a lot of forms of therapy or medication,
you have to take this pill for the rest of your life.
You have to be in therapy for years.
If you can do a mindset intervention,
it's done,
benefits are there,
it's locked in and you can have a five minute mindset intervention and,
and instead of taking,
you know,
prescription for the rest of your life.
What I've found to mitigate my addiction problems or my addictive tendencies is
just do a bunch of different things.
Yup.
I have a bunch of different activities that I do and the reason why I'm doing so
many different things is to keep from locking out.
Right,
exactly.
So you've like intuitively figured that out.
All right.
Okay.
Well I figured it out from trial and error over a long life of addiction.
I grew up being addicted to a bunch of different things.
At first it was art and then it became martial arts.
And then as I got older it became standup comedy and it became a pool.
I had a real problem with pool to a point where my manager thought it was
ruining my career.
Oh my God,
I was playing eight,
10 hours a day.
I was playing in tournaments.
All I want to do was play pool.
I would go do my comedy sets and then I go play pool till three,
four o'clock in the morning.
And then I would get up in the morning and go workout.
I go,
uh,
you know,
go do my comedy and do the same thing every night and all.
But all I was thinking about was the game.
I was thinking about like knocking the balls into the hole.
Like the,
they're the dopamine effect or whatever it is of,
of winning,
of or of being successful,
of running out the table of having the ball do what you want it to do.
Yeah.
And because it's so difficult,
the reward is so much like anything that's really,
like if you play a game,
it's really easy,
but when you win it doesn't mean anything.
But when you play a game that's really hard to do.
That reward is so
fucking exciting.
Yeah.
But this is interesting cause like you become a more interesting person as a
result of having all the things that you do.
Like you're like this really unusual that you have all of these things instead
of being hyper focused on one aspect.
Um,
so it's probably,
I mean it seems like a good strategy.
I'm just a broad spectrum junkie.
That might be,
that could be like a recipe for a good life though.
I mean I,
this is kind of independent,
interested in that idea now.
Like what you should that should,
that should be like a thing,
broad spectrum junkie.
I mean it works right now,
but it could go off the rails.
Yeah.
Well you gotta keep,
you gotta keep,
you gotta keep that circle why it's going off the rails several times in my
life.
But it's just,
she was like,
even I like with running,
like I,
I definitely use running for my mental health.
Um,
and if I get an injury that is really hard for me.
I have to replace it with something or else,
you know,
you go into a depression.
It's a big thing with Jujitsu guys.
It's very difficult for them to take the time off before they go back and train
again once they get injured.
Yeah.
And I have a cup of chronic injuries that I have because one particular of a
back injury,
there was a bulging disc that I just would,
I would ignore.
Right.
I would,
I would hurt it pretty bad.
And then two weeks later I'd be sparring again.
Yeah.
Because I was just needed that rush.
Until it got pretty chronic.
And then I had to take a long stretch off and really let it heal up.
But it,
can you give me that perspective?
It feels like,
I mean,
just hearing you say that makes me think how really how important is for people
to understand like how this system works so that you can say,
look,
my brain's telling me to go back and work out now.
Even though my doctor said don't do it and I can Google and it says,
stay off it for six weeks.
Um,
and to understand your brain is telling you that because it wants a dopamine
hit.
If you really want to rehabilitate properly,
you need to start doing other things that produce dopamine hits.
And that's,
I mean,
fantasy sports for example.
Do you get really into that for the season that you're taking off?
Um,
because that's you're making predictions,
so that's really,
that's not good work.
It wouldn't work for you.
No chance works for a lot of people playing poker then not you need to be
active.
Physically active.
Yeah.
There there's has to be actual physical movement and fucking that nervousness is
a big part of my adrenaline junky thing.
Yeah.
It's actual nerves.
It's like playing poker is,
it was never exciting to me.
Even if like people are gambling for a lot of money,
whereas playing pool is extremely exciting because there's the execution,
the physical explanation of things.
So you're going into flow state.
Yeah,
that's what that is,
right?
Too much.
Well,
I think my brain was wired with martial arts and competing,
which is extremely exciting,
but dangerous and thrilling and the thrills or so high,
like the thrills of competing or just beyond anything that you can ever get from
something that's nonphysical nonthreatening.
It's,
it's high level problem solving with dire physical health consequences.
Right.
So there's all sorts of craziness involved in it and the intensity and the focus
that you need.
So you that guy on the skateboard
really well then.
Okay.
Oh yeah.
Two well that's what's scary about it to me.
Yeah.
That could have fucking easily been me when I was 17 or 18 years old.
I understand all that shit.
That's why one of the things that freaked me out the most about those people
that are tight rope walking and doing all the jumping,
those squirrel suits or they jump off of cliffs and fly around.
Yeah.
That doesn't know.
It freaks me out is that I get it.
Yeah.
That's what freaks me out.
Race,
car driving,
all that shit is like,
I understand what this guy's doing.
He's feeding that monster in his brain that needs to be shocked and scared and
thrilled and what's next and you know,
it's like you feel alive,
not just feel alive but hyper.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Hyper alive in a very hot,
it's funny cause you were asking about focus earlier and obviously when you go
into that like the intense state where there is high stakes,
high risk,
your attention,
it's so super focused,
a time slows down and you're able to see more process more.
So that could be part of,
I mean did you,
you're interested in,
in focus because that's a part of that experience at high,
which you don't get.
There's,
I mean there's lots of highs where you're not going to happen.
That's kind of heightened focus and attend.
There's that and there's this state of peace that's achieved when you've
overcome almost insurmountable obstacles and fear and nervousness,
everything else,
like whatever weird problems that you might be dealing with,
with your personal life.
They seem so inconsequential.
Like,
uh,
like when I would have like a relationship problems or girl,
I was dating some craziness.
We're about to break up.
I would go spar and I would be like,
who gives a fuck?
Yeah.
You know,
and,
and you know,
I would,
I remember one time having this conversation with this girl I was dating was
like so dramatic and nonsense.
I'm like,
so then I guess we're breaking up.
I mean,
like what,
what are we going to do?
Like I fuck,
I can't do this.
Like either we like each other or we don't like each other.
Either they're going to hang out and have fun or we're not going to hang out
anymore.
Like,
I don't want to do this anymore.
oh,
you're so cold,
your early twenties.
Yeah,
sure.
Fucking to do you really gain perspective instead of wallowing around in this,
because I think there's an addictive aspect of relationships to breakup,
makeup thing of the,
the highs and the lows of like,
there are some people that are addicted to arguing in relationships.
Oh,
sure.
Falling in love is an addiction.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
it's literally the same process.
It's the narrowing of attention on one day.
The only that person gets you that excited gets you that,
um,
the bunch of biological tricks.
Yeah.
Age too,
because your body's trying to get you to breed.
Yeah.
And what's really,
then you get the really problematic relationships when that happens for one
person and not the other.
And that's why you get stalkers.
Yeah.
Well you get like,
but it's like,
it's why it's why somebody seems you don't understand.
Even if you're dating and you kind of liked that person,
but they're already there down the road.
They're like,
they are there,
they are in love,
they are addicted.
And then your behavior might seem totally crazy to me because I'm not there yet.
And even though I liked you,
because you're further along in that process and that sort of narrowing of
attention,
uh,
I freak out where it's,
you know,
maybe if I had waited a few more weeks,
I might've been that I might've been far enough along that it actually doesn't
scare me off.
You know,
like people who fall in love at different rates.
It's not,
it's not totally though that you're a crazy person and I'm a normal person and
therefore I shouldn't date you.
It's just your further,
the biochemical processes look a little faster for you.
Um,
it was,
I think like there are couples who break up too soon because one of them came
kind of cut further along in the addiction process and the other what a weird
way to look at it.
But yeah,
I mean,
and also it's like the same exact person.
You could meet them six months later and they're perfect,
right?
Yeah.
Or you meet them right now because maybe they have enough going on yeah.
In their life that they fall in love slower.
Sure.
Right.
Because you'll fall in love faster if there's nothing else getting you excited
in your day.
Right.
Well,
it's also that term fall in love.
Like what,
what exactly is going on there?
Like what does that mean?
Right.
You know,
you're just sinking up whatever personality aspects that you have holes and
square pegs in round holes and everyone's trying to figure out where everything
fits in.
And then there's also a weird thing where,
uh,
we've all had friends that alter who they are when they start dating someone.
Yeah.
It's very strange to see too,
you know,
like they'll stop talking to some of their friends or they change their behavior
pretty radically and you're like,
Whoa,
what's going on?
You're like fitting in to this mold of the other person requires.
Yeah.
Like one person is either more dominant or you're both like super fucking
codependence.
So you need each other all the time.
Yeah.
I have a friend.
This motherfucker can't go anywhere without his girlfriend.
He doesn't do anything without her.
I mean,
Eh,
w invite them over for a podcast.
Boom.
Brings his girlfriend,
you know,
come on over for the game.
Oh,
she's here to great.
You know,
like he doesn't go to the movies,
didn't do anything like they were like,
does he,
is he happy?
It's a fucking mess.
He's a mess.
But the two of them are a mess together and it's like in escapable pair.
Gotcha.
Yeah.
That may,
they're happy,
messy,
happy.
Maybe.
I Dunno.
I don't know either.
Okay.
Well,
what is happiness?
That's strange.
I mean,
it's like they're not depressed.
They're not jumping off bridges.
Yeah.
You know,
the Bolton,
they're not shooting heroin and that was all sounds good.
Yeah.
Like what,
what is it that makes people addicted to each other?
Cause they most certainly get addicted to each other.
Yeah.
Like the feeling when someone breaks up with you when you can't believe they're
gone.
Yeah.
Like that is like,
I'll like someone's stolen something from you.
Like they've stolen your happiness by taking off and just simply leaving you
alone.
Yup.
You,
they are,
they are a part of you like your whole,
your,
your whole is missing a slice.
Yeah.
Like the whole of,
I know that
it means all the metaphors that people use.
It really does feel that way.
Yeah.
But isn't that a biological trick?
Just to get us to breed,
like you stick around long enough to make a baby and then,
you know,
fall in love with the baby so that you raise it and so that,
that baby can go and have a baby in the sense of community that you have all
sorts of is addictive and it keeps you together,
which ensures survival.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
that's why cooperation feels good.
It's why kindness feels good.
I mean,
I'm still tricky.
It is.
And it's like,
I don't know.
You can,
I mean,
I'm a very practical person.
I mean I think I try to help people feel good.
I want to feel good,
know,
cooperation and kindness.
You know,
those things help society and help evolution and like we're stronger together.
Yeah.
And it feels good.
Uh,
like that's,
that's practical and you and I don't mind that.
And you know,
evolution is kind of tricking me.
I mean,
I have two babies.
I have a seven month old twin daughters.
Uh,
you know,
uh,
if,
if this is a trick of biology,
how I feel about them,
I'm totally cool with that because it feels good.
Yeah.
That's biology's trick to me.
It tells me it feels good.
I like it.
Thank you.
Biology for giving me these feelings I never have before.
Yeah.
I mean you can kind of intellectualize it down to the point where it's no longer
enjoyable cause he's,
it isn't life itself a trick in a sense because it's really temporary no matter
what.
You can accumulate all the Audis and,
and beautiful houses and boats you want,
but the end of the day it's over.
You know,
like you use the sunrises and sunsets and you've got a certain amount of time
and that's it.
So you can intellectualize that to the point where we're like,
well then what's the fucking point?
I'm just going to end it now.
And some people do do that.
They almost get to this thing where they can't be in the moment because they
don't know how long the moment lasts.
And the anticipation of the moment ending is just too freaky.
So like fuck this,
I'm out.
It's sort of the same thing as my friend who can't play the video game if he's
going to lose and he pulls the plug.
I mean really there's a lot of lot of the same sort of qualities and
characteristics of that kind of thinking.
I was like,
there's over intellectualizing or over analyzing to the point where you can't
even enjoy what it is.
I feel like I really want to work on this friend of yours like a figure like
video games therapy to like,
well it sounds like an interesting project EGOMANIAC.
You don't want to do it too much problems.
I like by like I liked,
they do.
Like how would you help somebody who can't lose
usually be so happy that you're trying to help them because that means you're
talking about him.
It's like you're focusing on him.
It was a lot of awe but no,
I mean he's alive.
He lives in America is not an Ethiopia living in a grass house,
you know?
It's like he's lucky as fuck.
Yeah.
You got to think I,
I,
it's at a certain point in time that there's,
there's,
there's levels to,
to like happiness and harmony,
the harmony that you achieve with the environment that you find yourself in and
the more chaos that you create and the more problems that you create just to
solve those problems.
It's got it,
that that energy keeps you from doing something else and that energy is going to
block you from the other pursuits.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah.
I mean,
you need to take committed action towards positive things
and in a sense,
the entirety of your life
is again,
of course.
Yes,
it is.
I have a kind of funny story about that.
Um,
you know,
I did the Colbert report a few years ago and when you did that,
she'd break character.
So when he comes,
not,
no,
not well,
not exactly.
He comes in the dressing room beforehand and they don't do a pre show interview
because they want you to be kind of off guard and off balance.
And he comes in and he says,
you know,
have you seen the show?
Okay,
I'm going to be in character and a,
I'm going to be really stupid and stubborn and your job is to disabuse me of my
stupid and stubborn ideas.
Um,
and they said,
now let me ask you a question,
uh,
is,
you know,
his life,
a game.
And I was like,
is this,
is he like,
is he practicing,
you know,
is this like I am,
I,
are we practicing some kind of witty rapport for the show or whatever.
So I'm like,
I'm trying to go into that mode.
And I'm like,
well,
you know,
yes,
of course it is.
And he's like,
if life is a game and we spend all our time playing it,
why are we so bad at it?
And I'm like,
I'm like totally thrown off of Mike.
Is he being like Phyllis,
I don't like,
anyway,
it turned out he was actually being quite philosophical and he had like,
he had all of these,
you know,
sort of thoughts about,
I mean,
we've started mentioning philosophy books,
he'd ride and everything.
And I was like,
oh,
okay,
this is like,
not like a,
you know,
ready like banter practice.
He was like,
really thinking about that.
And I always,
uh,
I have an,
I mean to return to that question and try to come up with a better answer for
him someday.
Well,
it's a complicated game and there's no instruction book.
That's why we're so bad at it.
I mean,
it's not everybody's bad and you run into people,
you go,
wow,
this person is a really cool game going on.
Yeah.
You know,
but it is just a game.
And essentially what the problem is that there's loaded words,
like the word addiction is a loaded word.
It's a loaded term.
I think the word game is a loaded term too.
It's a complicated series of events that you're trying to manage.
Yup.
And you're trying to manage risk and reward and benefit and then positive and
negative aspects of behavior.
Essentially.
It's exactly the same as the game.
They're completely indistinguishable.
Yeah.
It's one of them is just open ended and there's,
you know,
there's no clear pathway.
It's a game that literally you're standing in the middle of the universe,
Bam.
And especially in 2015 if you have the means you can get on a plane and go to
another part of the game.
You know,
you could just hop on a plane and you know,
we were talking before this podcast started about,
uh,
the radio lab,
a podcast that's today,
um,
about that guy who was on my podcast,
Cory Nolton and shot that Rhino.
Like that's a guy who took the game and decided to go to a fucking place.
He totally doesn't belong or has never,
you know,
never is not born there,
whatever shouldn't say doesn't belong,
but a completely different area of the game and he's doing something over there
and everybody over on this part of the game,
it's like,
what the fuck are you doing over there?
Like some guy gets on a boat and decided to sail across the world,
right?
Like,
Whoa,
whoa.
What are you doing?
Right?
Well,
he decided that he's going to go to a different part of the board and he's going
to get in a boat and he's going to drink rainwater and tried to catch fish and
travel across the fucking ocean.
She's like,
people are playing,
right?
Different kinds of games.
So like the guy who wants to kill a rhino,
that's a combat game and the person who wants to sail around in the boat is
doing exploration and adventure game and other people are doing the,
you know,
collection game where you are acquiring resources.
Everything that the Rhino guys doing the collection game well,
yeah.
Weird way.
Right?
He's collecting bodies.
Yes.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
And I think the,
the guy who's on the boat is doing the collection game too,
cause he's collecting accolades.
You know,
I've made it across the ocean.
Oh right.
Yeah.
The real way to do is go across the ocean.
Don't tell anybody.
Right.
Where are you bidding for the last six months?
You know,
just chilling,
trying to find myself.
Well you know,
you were on a boat
when Isaiah to training for a marathon.
I was like,
I'm not telling anybody because I don't,
I want it to like just internal.
Yeah.
I want it to be from,
well you know,
cause it's like this weird bias some people have about renters that like they
brag about it a lot or like they do it to like show off
Gino who says that people who wish they were running.
Oh I really believe that.
Yeah.
Cause if you run,
like I have my friend Cameron,
Cameron Hanes,
he's run two ultra marathons.
Hey he'll,
you know,
post about it on his Instagram or he'll show you his time or something like
that.
But he's trying to,
like,
he's an athlete and these sponsored by a bunch of companies and part of his Gig
is that he inspires people and he really feels good about that.
It'll be genuine thing that he does,
takes people running up these mountains.
But you'll see these people at like bitch about it.
Like this guy's running,
he's run a hundred miles in 24 hours.
If that's unimpressive,
not worth,
then you need to go look in the mirror and find out what the fuck actually
impresses you.
You post a picture of your breakfast you can't get mad about.
Yeah.
Okay.
Then yeah,
my eggs.
Yeah.
Yes.
I mean it's like,
well,
why do people get upset that you say you're going to run a marathon and why
would anybody get upset?
It's hard to run a marathon.
You've got to run for three and a half,
four hours,
whatever the hell your time is.
Yeah.
That's up fucking long time.
It's hard for me to do 20 minutes on the elliptical machine and not get bored.
Yeah.
I could keep going for a lot longer.
But at 20 minutes I'm like,
fuck,
am I done?
Jay is as Christ get this over with.
When someone says they ran a marathon,
you start to question your own resolve.
Yes.
Which is like one of the reasons why they do it.
You're showing your score.
Yeah.
You're showing your game score and people are getting pissed.
Too High.
Fucking showing her highest score.
But sometimes,
sometimes I will post a terrible run cause I like you don't want to be too
inspiring that people feel like they can't do it.
Like fuck those people.
I'll do it slow run so that people will see like,
oh you're tricking you into doing shitty scores.
They're tricking you.
That's true.
So true.
Well there's definitely that.
There's is a lot of people who when someone will accomplish something I will,
I'm fascinated by watching the observers and one of the Instagram observers of
the most fascinating cause whenever I go to someone's page,
someone's done something cool.
Like you know my friend Cameron running a hundred miles,
I'll look at the,
the,
the negative comments and I go to their Instagram page and they're almost always
blocked.
It's almost always private,
like locked.
Like you,
you have to,
you have to be one of their accepted friends on the comment on their pictures
because they're hiding.
Right.
Cause they're not putting themselves out there.
They're not showing their life
and which means they don't understand the vulnerability involved.
Like if you were,
if you had the experience of having other people write on your stuff the same
way that you were doing on someone else,
you might not be doing that.
Well,
they're playing the low,
they're playing tic TAC toe,
right?
Yeah.
Or someone else's out there playing chess.
That's gotta be like the new like zing my man.
You're playing tic TAC toe.
Yeah.
That's like tic Tac toe play a mother fucker.
I mean it is kind of what it is.
If life is this really super complex,
open ended game where essentially if you live in a free culture like we do,
you know,
we're not living in North Korea where you're assigned a job and if you don't cry
when something happens,
you know,
you go to jail,
you,
your,
your game is essentially open ended.
Yep.
It's not,
that's one of the reasons why when people get out of jail,
they find themselves like institutionalize is the word,
but they find themselves so trapped in the game of jail.
Yeah.
That's how their brain is wired.
It's really extremely difficult for them to deal with the open ended game of
life.
Yeah.
I mean,
even for UC it with when someone graduates college,
kids who have been from the top colleges who have been taught to play the game
of achieving and achieving in this really rigid structure,
and then they get out into the world and nobody's telling them here,
here are the things you have to do to be considered a good student or be
successful.
And then they just lose it.
It's too much.
Yeah.
Because they don't,
they are not,
they have not been directing their own game.
Right.
It's like you,
if you,
if you haven't been designing the game now you have to suddenly acquire that
skill.
It's also one of the problems that some people have with career academics.
People that never participated in the real world.
They went from college to teach in college and then they also,
they require these rigid standards of behavior and things.
I know,
I heard your show about that.
Yeah.
Dot.
The Atlantic article.
Awesome.
Yeah,
that is,
well,
it's interesting because I've been so steeped in psychology literature,
um,
and uh,
a lot of the folks who play super better are traumatized and they've,
they've been through PTSD and it is absolutely true that avoiding triggers
prolongs the problem.
I mean,
so I,
I can look at the scientific literature and say trigger warnings are actually
not,
they're not going to help.
They're going to make you weaker over time.
It's like we were talking about,
you know,
oh,
I'm so scared of the bad guy.
I have to avoid everything that is a trigger.
Um,
we know that that's not true.
So when I,
you know,
when I hear about that,
I,
you know,
I wish,
and I try to talk to people and I tweet when that article came out,
I tweeted about it and I have a lot of people who follow me who are,
you know,
have PTSD and they're very conflicted about whether they're supposed to avoid
triggers and they like trigger warnings cause they think it's going to keep them
safe.
But for everything we know is that you need to get better at controlling your
reaction to the trigger.
Avoiding it doesn't help.
So I can,
I can see why that's so frustrating to people.
Well,
the,
for the,
one of the most frustrating aspects of that article in particular was that
what's going on in colleges today is it's,
it's a control issue.
Yeah.
It's,
they're controlling behavior in such an extreme way that they're there.
They want to penalize people for micro aggressions.
Right.
Which is like you say something and I go,
alright.
Which is just a part of a fucking human interaction with it.
Like if I say something to you and you give me a sarcastic response,
I have to decide,
you know what,
I don't enjoy communicating with her because she,
she makes me feel bad.
Or I have to say maybe I'm fucking Douchey and maybe people react to me in a
negative way and I should think about not what I want to say or how I want to
say things,
but rather how people might view what I'm saying and how they take it in.
And maybe I'm just an ineffective communicator and maybe what's going on here is
just,
you know,
there's,
there's like two people playing soccer.
Okay.
They're both trying to hit the ball and they collide into each other.
Who's fault is it?
It's,
well,
they're both the,
it's just non smooth movement.
Yup.
And that,
that sort of interaction that you would get when you're trying to hit a soccer
ball.
It's very similar to the interaction that you had when two people communicating
with each other,
your e the colliding people.
One person is not necessarily totally responsible for that collision.
Yeah.
They're both sort of responsible for it.
And there's a,
there's a,
a whole dance going on with poor decision making in the moment and lack of
experience and collisions and lack of an understanding of the consequences of
those collisions.
All that is a part of going to college and all that is a part of growing up.
And when you have people that are shielding you from micro aggressions.
Yeah.
All that shit is just a part of being a human and dealing with your hormones and
emotions and yeah,
you're separated from your family for the first time and now you're in Michigan
and some fucking crazy university and you've got some fat,
stupid teacher that's never even existed outside of the real world.
And they're dictating your behavior patterns and telling you you're not allowed
to use a male and female pronouns anymore.
And all this.
I liked the teachers.
I mean,
you know,
I have a lot of friends who are,
who are,
you know,
they teach at university,
so that was dry.
I will remove the fat,
stupid,
well I'm just surprised.
Let's say skinny smart really yet or whatever.
I'm fat,
stupid.
Does that even mean like physically what I mean is just like this,
this bloated sort of lazy entity that is creating this environment where you're,
you're establishing this artificial realm.
So is looking at what's going on.
This is not coming from instructors or faculty that this is coming from the
students and some of the phenomenon.
But it certainly,
it certainly was,
uh,
I mean it,
it,
it's,
this is definitely a younger phenomena.
It doesn't like something like deeply entrenched people who came up.
I mean,
my professors are totally like friends who are professors are totally weirded
out by it,
don't know how to handle it.
They're not creating that culture.
I mean,
it's definitely something coming from the students who have been raised in this
culture of,
you know,
uh,
I mean it's that it's a very protective culture and you don't,
nobody should have their feelings hurt.
Nobody,
you know,
nobody should experience failure or rejection.
I mean,
I,
I feel like it's more from that culture then from anything related to like
contemporary academia or faculty
thing because isn't contemporary academia academia overwhelmingly liberal and
progressive?
Uh,
I mean,
I think so.
I think on the political spectrum,
yeah,
when you have something that's moving in one very particular direction,
oftentimes people will try to outdo themselves or are not in control.
I mean
this is,
I think the reason why a student culture would have so much impact on this is
because universities are now like business models and the customer is always
right.
I mean that's not,
the professor is not the one who is,
uh,
who is going to like the professors more often than not resist.
It's really more at the level of,
uh,
the,
the business side of a college that is trying to make,
you know,
this,
uh,
make,
make this a good customer experience for the student.
I mean,
I think that is that it's more of the divine.
I don't think the,
the political affiliations of faculty is not,
I mean,
none of that is really what's going on.
It's really more about the students pay so much money for college now and they
expect lots of perks and they expect their,
they're paying for a certain experience.
Um,
I think that is really where you're seeing a lot of the friction come because
that's particularly younger generation is,
um,
seems to be if you look at,
you know,
what a lot of the experts are saying they want,
they don't want the things that feel painful or feel like failure or feeling
stress.
Well,
if that's the case,
then why are they a pointing out all these flaws and all these other people's
behavior to control them and flaws in the way people express themselves.
Flaws.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
it's,
part of it is obviously things need to change,
right?
I mean,
like what needs to change?
For instance,
I'm a woman.
I play games.
If I log into an online video game,
I don't want to be called a comment every time I log in.
Does that happen a lot?
Yeah,
of course.
And do you think that happens a lot because of what we talked about earlier,
where there's the interaction of just dealing in text?
This is a very strange and the interaction without people being right there with
each other.
Yes.
I mean,
absolutely.
Um,
seems like totally unnatural,
right?
Yes,
yes.
And people,
I mean,
I don't,
that doesn't happen to me in real life.
Right.
That's what I was going to ask.
Like how many people in real life say those things to you?
Nobody.
Yeah.
Like how bizarre,
right?
Yeah.
All of a sudden you enter into this world.
So isn't that a function almost of the world itself being completely unnatural,
more so than then the people being any different in that world?
I'm not sure.
But I mean,
so all of those say
there are things that people say and do in everyday life that are legitimately
offensive.
Sure.
Uh,
I mean,
I don't use the terminology microaggressions,
I don't use it,
the trigger warning terminology.
So I think we're like in this period where on one hand things do need to change
and some ways,
you know,
you,
you have Nobel laureate scientist giving speeches where they say that it's,
he doesn't like to have women in the lab because either they fall in love with
you or you fall in love with them and then you can't work together.
I mean when some,
when a Nobel laureate says that to a conference of,
you know,
young scientists that that's not helpful I don't think,
but I know that that was taken out of context,
you know,
the full extent.
I mean it was a joke and he was also talking about his wife and because he met
his wife in the lab and,
and he was also making himself to be for his,
it was a very self deprecating,
you didn't know the extent of it.
I did read some sort of
re reassessment of that.
Yep.
Dawkins printed the,
uh,
a full version of what he said and it's very different also.
Everyone is laughing.
I read the full version.
Yeah.
Um,
but so it's like,
so this is actually a perfect example because,
so if he was joking,
right.
So his intentions are totally good.
Is it possible that it's still not helpful to make that,
that kind of a statement?
That's,
I think that's what people are talking about,
right?
Uh,
when,
if,
if on one hand there's a lot of interest trying to increase the number of women
in science and technology,
is it possible that somebody would hear that and still be kind of demotivated by
it or kind of have that sink in?
So I think people are,
when they're,
when we're discussing these things,
uh,
I,
you don't have to police other people's language,
but I think it's,
I still think it's useful to say that might not be helpful.
Yeah.
The,
there's a,
an article on the leak transcript,
uh,
the leak transcript.
W w what happened was the people that saw it thought it,
like,
at least some of them thought was funny and,
but there were aspects of what he said that we're probably Clum busy,
right.
Swanky or,
you know,
he was trying to be funny and he's really just sort of an odd guy who's a
scientist.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
people decided that this is an awesome target.
Like,
let's go after it.
Right.
And to make an example,
which happens on the UN,
I mean,
the whole people get shamed on the Internet.
Now that's,
that's what happens.
Um,
I mean my,
you know,
I don't have any expertise in this area,
so it's probably not,
you know,
worth me know
bound.
The official quote he says is strange as such a chauvinist monitor like me,
has it been asked to speak to women scientist?
Let me tell you about my trouble with girls.
His trouble with girls,
three things happen when they were in the lab.
You Fall in love with them,
they fall in love with you and when you criticize them,
they cry.
Perhaps we should make separate labs for boys and girls now.
Seriously,
I'm impressed with the economic development of a second.
This was before
not fair.
Of course he,
it was,
it was him joking.
Yeah.
But he's definitely,
he's joking,
playing on stereotypes that girls cry and girls can't handle criticism.
I mean,
I'm just saying,
yeah,
I,
I'm not gonna say that I think is totally fine to say,
hey,
when you say these things,
it might result in some girl thinking,
wait,
maybe I'm not going to be a good scientist because,
because people say that girls aren't good in the lab or whatever it is.
I wouldn't say it.
That's yeah,
I try to be,
I tried to be,
you know,
even when we say things like about people who play games a lot,
um,
oh,
they're wasting their lives.
You know,
why don't you go out and do something real?
Um,
I don't think that's useful to say either.
I think that that's actually,
uh,
can be really damaging identity.
Generalize,
you know,
men,
yes.
And women do that and girls aren't good at being in the lab and it's,
it's,
it's damaging.
And I think now he understands that a joke like that as innocent as a,
he might have intended it to be when you're reading it in a text form,
especially in you taking some of it out of context,
it can be,
it can be a offensive,
it can be hurtful for someone who's considering like how many girls were reading
that they were considering a possible career in science.
One,
I don't have to with fucking people like this.
Like I don't want to,
I'm not gonna cry in your lab,
asshole.
I just want to do work.
I want to be a scientist.
Yeah.
So we don't need to like police people to have this conversation.
Right.
You know?
So
what does that sort of expose in some ways it exposes a,
yeah.
Prevalent attitudes,
um,
that this guy who is this esteemed Nobel winning scientist has this attitude,
you know,
that he thinks it's funny to joke around about it and they're like,
even if he's not a sexist or a bad guy,
him making this joke about himself being some chauvinist monster and it's
become,
one of the things is because his wife is a prominent feminist and so he jokes
around about him being a chauvinist monster.
Yeah.
You know?
Well that makes sense.
Yeah.
I mean that's,
it's all out of context and it's all also,
you're dealing with a guy who's,
who's real focus is,
is research,
not social interaction.
Right.
He's not like a nuanced speaker is not a guy who is a carefully considered a
speaker who gets on stage and thinks about everything and the impact of all,
I mean,
he,
like we were talking about like the awkward interaction that people might have
in college.
Well,
this guy's awkward interaction is him being forced to write a speech.
Like if he did this a bunch of times,
he'd probably get really way better at it.
And you have,
you sat down with him alone in,
you guys were just talking over a glass of wine.
Maybe you'd understand how his brain works better.
Yeah,
maybe I would have spoke.
Yeah.
If,
if something offends you,
it's more useful to have a conversation about it then to just start.
Yeah.
But it's fun to blog and shit.
All of this guy is this guy,
he's old and he's white and he's famous or so.
Well write a book about the neurochemistry of outrage and because it's,
it's its own high,
you know,
it's recreational,
recreational outrage.
Yeah.
Without a doubt.
A real thing.
Right?
Yeah.
And I think that that's what's going on in colleges and that people are finding
when you're in college,
it's like when you were talking about the addiction that people have to video
games.
And then one of the things that sort of stimulates that addiction is if you're
trying to avoid things in your regular lottery.
Okay.
Well,
if you're in college,
the,
the overwhelming anxiety of being a young person who has gone from being,
living with their parents,
going to high school,
now you're in college and you were just a couple of years away from the cliff of
real world,
like you're fucking sliding towards it and you're trying to define it and
redefine it and change it and establish yourself.
And then along the way comes things that you can be angry at.
Well,
you will point your fucking fury.
There are really unmeasured are unbalanced fury at those things where it doesn't
necessarily make sense,
but it makes sense to you because what you're really doing is you're avoiding
the adjuncts have social anxiety of,
of,
of uh,
sexual rejection and all the,
all the shit that makes a person feel weird things.
And you channel that towards micro aggressions.
Are you that towards someone treat,
you know,
deciding to address you with a male or a female pronoun.
You know,
there's like,
there's a lot of weirdness to being a person and that,
that,
but you know,
the last thing I want to say about this is part,
it is,
I think people are just trying to make new roles for the game.
Right.
You know,
and,
and when you're trying to change the rules of a game that is really upsetting.
If you're in the middle of the game,
you're playing a game and stuff is like,
ah,
wait,
totally,
can't do that now.
She,
we've always been here and she,
yeah,
yeah.
It's like,
oh,
you're playing soccer.
You can't kick the ball anymore with your feet.
Right.
And you're in the middle of the game.
Right,
right.
Right.
So,
but it doesn't mean as a game designer was say,
it doesn't mean that there isn't a better game that actually could have
different rules,
but it's really upsetting to be in the middle of a game and have somebody say,
wait.
Right.
Those aren't the rules.
So,
you know,
maybe we should,
maybe we should.
Um,
I don't know.
I don't know how to do it better because I mean,
look,
I'm a progressive person and I'm glad that things are changing in society in
lots of ways,
you know,
then I'm excited about
like,
what makes you happy?
What do you,
what do you think is good about the changes in society in a progressive?
Well,
I'm,
I'm really glad that we have marriage equality now.
I'm really excited about that.
I'm glad that,
um,
I mean paternity and maternity leave,
you know,
becoming more people having longer maternity leave and the same length paternity
leave for dads as a new parent.
I,
you know,
really excited to see companies doing that.
Um,
and I like,
I like,
you know,
uh,
I like that we're starting to talk about income inequality.
I mean optimistic that there will be changes in that direction.
And I think that,
uh,
I think the black lives matter is hugely important movement.
I think so.
I think there's a lot of conversations going on right now where people are angry
or have struggled or feel like they've been playing a rigged game.
And,
uh,
so it's not as long going to be pleasant and not all the tactics are going to be
effective or good either.
But,
uh,
the general attitude is definitely moving in a more progressive direction.
I think so.
And somebody
who has been,
you know,
I've,
I've had Twitter,
you know,
hordes yelling at me because they thought that I was breaking one of the new
rules of how we're supposed to,
like what did people yell at?
You know,
one of the big instance I had was,
uh,
about,
my recommendations for playing tetris after a trauma.
So there've been multiple randomized control studies now out of Oxford
University showing that if you play tetris within 24 hours of a traumatic event,
it will reduce the flashbacks.
You have the severity of flashbacks and other PTSD symptoms because it occupies
your brain and prevents your brain from kind of locking in and,
and obsessive compulsive way on the trauma.
Right?
So this is,
I think this is incredibly important advice that everyone should know.
Kind of like drop and roll.
You know,
if you catch on fire,
you know what to do.
Everybody should have tetris on their phone and have it available to them.
If,
if,
because I know having suffered flashbacks from my own head injury,
how,
I mean I would have nightmares and beat of which I was hitting my head and I
would feel it as if a real,
and I'd wake up and I'd be convinced that I had hit my head in the middle of the
night and was going to have this experience all over again.
Um,
just nightmares constantly.
So I know how bad is no one people to do it.
When I started tweeting about it,
people I got told that there needed to be like trigger warnings on my tweets
because I was mentioning Ptsd and I might make somebody think about like a
trauma that they experienced and um,
while they're trying to change the game.
Yeah.
So it's like I under,
I don't,
you know,
I've,
I've been on the other side of it where people have said that I'm doing it
wrong,
but at the same time I recognize there are people who are suffering or angry or
they have been at a disadvantage because of the way the game is rigged.
And so I'm okay with there being like,
we're all going to be uncomfortable for awhile as these things change.
And that's,
you know,
so you're uncomfortable with being unjustly accused of being insensitive when
you're bringing out the scientific research that shows that a game can help you
with trauma.
Yeah,
I mean,
I,
I think I've,
I'm,
I'm going to keep doing it,
you know,
but I understand that the people who say it are hurting the people who,
who are telling me that I'm triggering them.
So irrational.
I think that all irrational behavior like that should either be ignored or shit
on.
I really do.
I just think it's dangerous.
I think it's dangerous when it gets pointed out.
Like your,
your science,
you're pointing out the scientific aspects of a very specific activity that's
very good for trauma.
And they're saying that you shouldn't talk about this now.
That's nonsense.
Well,
that's why I still talk about it.
Right.
But I don't have to get into a fight with them.
Yeah.
No,
you certainly don't.
You should ignore them.
Right.
Or Shit on them,
depending on how you feel.
Yeah.
But I think that there's,
there's definitely a,
I like how we're defining life as like a giant game or is equal to a giant game.
Cause I think that that's what's going on also with the reaction,
the negative reaction to progressive thinking.
Now like a,
I was tweeting something about,
um,
this woman in,
uh,
Kentucky that was trying to stop people from getting gay marriage licenses.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
I really,
I took a few days where I wasn't paying attention to Twitter that much and I
didn't know that there was this giant movement supporting this woman.
And I went to Mike Huckabee's fucking Twitter page and saw that this crazy old
asshole was like saying that there's a war against Christians.
And that like Hashtag religious liberty and so it was like that doesn't have a
religious liberty doesn't mean you enforce your religion on other people.
Right.
But that's so crazy.
Yeah and there was so much blow back.
I got so many people tweeting at me angrily tweeting at me for saying like,
and I tweeted something about Ted Cruz about how ridiculous his views are on
marriage and like that he's probably gay and I'm like if you've listened to the
way that guy talks,
he's super feminine.
Like there's like how many times we have to see this where these men,
right?
Because I have a bit that I used to do my act that there's two types of people
that hate gay marriage.
It's either you're really dumb or you're secretly worried the decks are
delicious.
Those are the people.
And like this guy is like there's something going on here.
Why does he care so much about two people that are in love that,
but watching the people that are angry that the game is being redefined and
there was all this,
it was all this Christian stuff that was attached to it.
Like,
well,
guess what?
Guess what else it says not to do in the Bible it says not to get divorced.
Like this lady,
the same lady has been divorced three times.
She's on her fourth marriage.
Guess what else it says you're not supposed to have tattoos.
Okay.
Those people were tattooed with religious symbols on them.
You've got a cross on your arm and you tattooed it.
She fucking,
you gotta read the whole book like crazy.
Like the things that they choose and it,
what it is,
is they trying to,
they're trying to define the world that they're playing in.
Yeah.
We're trying to define right.
And I think it's important because even though I might disagree,
I mean I,
I vehemently disagree with people whose perspective seem to be fueled by hate.
But I think it's important to still try to have the empathy or the,
the mental insight to understand why does this make them feel so bad?
I think what you just said,
and you have the feeling that you thought you understood the rules.
I mean religion is a set of roles.
You thought you understood it.
You're,
you're playing the game right.
You're doing it right.
Um,
and it is,
it is psychologically distressing to have somebody else tell you were playing a
different game.
Yeah.
You know,
your game sucks.
Um,
and you're not going to go to play it anymore.
Uh,
I,
I try to understand where those feelings are coming from because if you're going
to change people's minds,
you know,
you have to,
I think you have to acknowledge that they are in a real,
they are really in distress about this,
you know,
then I doing this just to be jerks.
I mean they,
this is why change is fall to them.
Well,
why are they in distress about something that doesn't directly affect them?
But it's because of what you just said.
Because it is,
it is,
it feels,
it's,
they have committed to a framework,
a set of roles and,
and,
and put,
that's it.
Once you're in it,
you're in it and,
and you know,
when you're playing a game,
you always try to stop the cheaters and you protect the boundaries of the game.
That's,
that's a mindset you get into and they're just,
they think they're just doing it.
What kind of country that was established by Christian values.
Yes.
The fucking games locked.
Yeah.
Okay.
You can't change the rules.
That's,
it really does seem like we've,
we've kind of touched on something here.
Yeah.
This is a,
this has been a really good one for me was the,
the,
the overall looking at the,
the whole existence as instead of defining it by the word game,
but looking at it with almost the same sort of a attitude or approach that you
would look at a game is a very beneficial good.
It's worked for me.
You can,
your eyes get big like saucers.
Like you,
like you did it,
you did it,
you scored,
you made it happen.
Yeah.
I think,
um,
also,
like the,
the,
the ebb and flow of culture,
like the things that are seemed to definitely,
even,
even though I resist like this nonsense about microaggressions and trigger
warnings and stuff like that,
I'm very happy that things are moving in the direction of acceptance.
Yeah.
Very happy that,
you know,
like you can be whatever the fuck you want.
You just saw you're a woman today.
Go ahead.
As long as you don't hurt anybody,
who cares?
This guy wants to wear dresses and you want,
he wants you to call him Jane now.
Fine.
Okay.
You know,
these two guys want to get married to each other.
Terrific.
You know,
these two people want to stop wearing makeup and they want to,
what do you give a shit?
Who Cares?
Or they want to dye their hair blue.
That's fine too.
Like eventually we'll all figure out that we are all just unique individuals
that are a part of giant,
this gigantic super organism and the most conducive way or the most harmonic
way,
harmonious way for us to interact with each other is to fuck with each other's
path.
The least whatever path you're on your way in your game,
as long as it doesn't negatively affect people.
As long as you're not a destroyer out there,
your path is to burn down to the people's houses.
Your path is to steal.
Your path has to to hurt people.
As long as that's not going on.
Why care and,
and then ultimately once that is established,
I think then we will focus on,
okay,
well what are our rear real issues are real issues?
Aren't gay people getting married to each other?
A real issues are the people that actually are burning houses down the people
that are stealing.
Yeah.
Like these are the real issues that people have.
People that are not micro aggressions,
but actual aggressions.
People that are actually committing crimes against each other and why are they
doing that?
Well,
what is wrong with their game?
What happened to them?
Like what,
what series of events have placed them in this sort of position?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Because it's not,
I mean,
people don't get into that in a vacuum.
No.
I think that's also something you realized once you have children.
Yeah.
Like you have now.
And as a father,
one of the things has changed radically in my life is seeing people now.
Like when I meet people,
I see them as babies that have grown up.
Like I don't see them as being in a static state.
Yeah.
You know,
and it's,
it's very strange,
like even assholes that,
I mean,
I'd look at them and even go,
that guy's a fucking asshole.
I think of them as like,
what happened to that person?
But you know,
that's like a,
that's I practice Zen Buddhism and that's like one of the big Buddhist
meditations is to picture people as babies.
Yeah.
When you feel hate for somebody,
try to visualize them all the way down to throw little baby self and picture
what they look like as a baby and to think about who they were when they were
that baby before all of life happened to them,
to make them into somebody that has now triggered these,
you know,
hate feelings of anger
in the womb.
You know,
I was talking to Michael Irvin famous pro football player who's talking to me
about kids that grow up in horrible environments,
dangerous volatile environments where the mother has all this cortisol in her
brain while the child in the womb and that the kid literally grows up like with
a short temper.
Yeah.
They literally,
they're developed out of the womb,
like constantly worried about stress and danger.
Yeah.
Hypervigilant.
All of that.
I've had feral cats.
I had a cat that was feral at her raised and uh,
he was fucking terrified of everything from the time he was a baby and a,
I've locked myself in a room with them when he was a kitten because there's the
only way like bond with him.
I stayed with him for like three,
I just put a bunch of books in the room and cat food and the litter box and be
like,
you and me,
dude,
we're hanging out and want to come near him.
And he'd be like,
he just jumped on the walls and like you'd never seen anything like a feral
kitten.
I mean he was really little to just a couple months old.
And uh,
when,
uh,
when I would get to them and pick them up.
Right.
He was talking [inaudible] like finally somebody loves me.
Like,
but then when you put them down,
like the same cat would just be,
yeah,
because his brain was programmed from the time he was a little baby.
Yeah.
And there was not a lot he could do.
I couldn't say that cat's ass asshole.
Well,
no,
that fucking cat was born under an apartment building,
you know,
and his mom was like running away from traffic and trying to eat rats or
whatever the fuck they could kill.
Yeah.
Well,
I think this is one of the reasons why game thinking is so powerful because you,
this is zoom out and see the bigger structure that it's,
it's,
there's always a bigger game and more pieces in play and you're getting other
people's,
you know,
strategies or actions or,
or the rules,
you know,
um,
and being able to zoom out and see that makes you feel,
I think will you have more perspective,
more wisdom and maybe more compassion for other people.
That's awesome.
Why people like to rightly so criticized,
very narrow minded,
small town thinking.
Yeah.
Small little environments,
insulated environments that are very,
you know,
very critic criticizing or very,
just to,
just to have their,
their way set and they don't have a wide variety of experiences they can draw
upon or they don't have a broad nuanced view of the board that there,
yeah.
Playing on.
Yeah.
So this is like,
this is giving me a lot of what a food for thought about.
I mean,
the links between social change and gainful thinking.
Yeah.
There's something there.
I think also as time is going on and uh,
this is one thing,
the,
the positive aspects of social media and of the Internet itself is that we're
getting more and more information instead of just accepting these preconceived
notions that we have about different groups of people.
Now we're being to so much data,
it's just inadvertently or a inarguably changing the way we view those groups
and that you are forced to like when you see like this black lives matter thing,
you see all these peaceful protests where these people are talking eloquently
speaking and showing video after video,
police brutality.
And then I've had,
I had a cop on Michael Wood who was a Baltimore retired Baltimore police officer
that talked about,
very openly talked about the institutionalized racism and about how they had
found a papers from the 1970s that we're describing how to behave in certain
environments that were exactly the same as what's going on now.
He's like,
this is a fucking system.
This is the,
I don't think that attitude existed just a few years ago.
People are looking at all that data now and they go,
it's slowly coming around and even the hard liners are dropping.
You know,
if they were at a 10 now they're at an a or a seven,
well I fucking kid,
you need to get all caught a school or something.
You know,
it's like everyone is sort of slowly recognizing the pieces that are in play.
It's a lot more complicated then we want to,
you know,
just narrowly sort of define them and these,
these really simplistic terms where it's not simple.
There's a series of interactions that are going on all over the globe are human
beings are trying to find their way.
And they're also realizing somewhere along the line that their parents weren't
these all knowing creatures.
Neither were their parents,
neither were the President Roosevelt or fucking Abe Lincoln.
They were all people that were trying to find their way as well.
And this is a group effort.
It's a group effort that's still going on and it's not even remotely done.
It's not even close.
Yeah.
So it's okay.
So instead of seeing the bigger picture,
we will see the bigger game and that will be,
that will guide us.
Yes.
Bringing all right back to super better.
All right.
You got to get out of here.
You're going to catch a flight.
So thank you very much.
Um,
I'll put your video up on Twitter and we'll put your,
the link to your book,
which is available right now.
Right?
Uh,
well it drops next Tuesday,
but you can buy it now.
Oh,
you buy it now,
but you can get it next Tuesday.
Okay.
All right.
Well,
thank you so much.
Really,
really appreciate it.
All right,
and uh,
what's your Twitter address
again?
It's an avant game.
Ava and t.
T a m Emmy.
You can just search for my name Jane Games.
It'll come up.
All right.
Beautiful.
Thank you so much.
Awesome time.
Okay.
Much.